Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove
und ich begrüße alle hier zur 210. Ausgabe vom CRE.
Und nachdem die letzte Sendung
sich mal wieder so richtig schön
in die Hardcore Computertechnologiewelt reingelegt hat
und alle wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen unter Schock stehen,
wie es denn jetzt hier weitergeht,
breche ich mal zu komplett anderen Ufern auf
und führ die Naturverbundenheit hier im Programm wieder ein.
Heute soll es gehen um die Jagd.
Oder sagen wir mal auch um die generelle Frage,
wie es eigentlich so steht mit dem Menschen und der Natur,
der Umwelt und all diesen ganzen Fragen, die dahinter stehen,
die vielleicht noch ein bisschen vielfältiger sind,
als man auf den ersten Blick glauben möchte.
Und dazu begrüße ich Jochen, Jochen Schumacher. Hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Willkommen bei CRE.
Ja Jochen, du bist Jäger.
Kann man sagen?
Ja auch, auch Jäger.
Auch Jäger, genau.
Auf keinen Fall nur.
Unter anderem bist du auch Podcaster, machst den "Jagd Funk".
Seit wann jetzt?
Seit drei Jahren jetzt bald ja.
Auch so ähnlich CRE.
So ein Interviewformat, wo du quasi nochmal so in diese Nische abtauchst
und da ja eigentlich auch schon sehr
breitbandig an dieses Thema herangegangen bist.
Ja es ist eine vielfältige Welt.
Der Mensch in der Welt und wie er sie gestaltet und davon gestaltet wird.
Da bündelt sich halt einfach viel in diesem Thema und
ich habe immer so das Gefühl,
nach jeder Antwort, die ich bekomme tun sich drei bis fünf neue Fragen auf und...
ein Füllhorn.
Vielleicht mal zu dir erstmal.
Wie muss man dich eigentlich so verorten?
Also es ist ja nicht unbedingt die einzige Welt, an der du so teilnimmst.
Und du warst da auch nicht immer schon oder?
Ja, ich bin schon heterogen.
Also groß geworden bin ich mit dem Spruch meiner Mutter:
"Die Engel backen Plätzchen."
Und das war der Fall, wenn
die August Thyssen-Hütte ihre Hochöfen angestochen hatte.
Ich bin also im Duisburger Norden groß geworden, in Duisburg Alt-Hamborn genau.
Meine Eltern hatten einen Elektroinstallationsbetrieb.
Ich bin der mittlere von drei Brüdern.
Und ich sage mal so, dieser Luxus praktisch jeden Tag alle drei Mahlzeiten
im Kreise der vollständigen Familie einzunehmen,
wie so ein Handwerksbetrieb halt früher funktionierte,
das ist aus heutiger Perspektive schon eine tolle Sache.
Also dieses Zuhause sein einfach,
mittags geht die Tür irgendwie auf und man verschwindet
und wenn man sauber wieder nach Hause kam,
dann sah man die Zweifel im Blick der Mutter.
Welche Zweifel?
Ja irgendwie: "Du bist sauber, das kann doch nicht sein."
Also wir sind ja überall rumgeturnt und die
Kreise wurden immer größer und die Abenteuer immer spektakulärer.
Die Werkstatt, die elterliche, die stand
vollständig zur Verfügung nur das Material für die Kunden,
das war unter Strafe natürlich verboten dort dranzugehen.
Aber aus Resten mit Schleifstein, Standbohrmaschinen und Schweißgeräten irgendwas zusammenzudengeln
und damit Spaß zu haben.
Also das waren so ja das Erkunden der Welt eben.
Das hast du dann betrieben?
Ja ja das habe ich so mit meinen Brüdern und mit Freunden betrieben.
Nicht immer zur Freude aller aber...
Aber so eine Elektroinstallationskarriere hast du dann nicht eingeschlagen?
Ja ich sage immer, ich bin mit 220 Volt und im rechten Winkel erzogen worden.
Mein Vater war ein sehr ausgeprägter Handwerker
und ich habe im Grunde ab dem es gesetzlich möglich und erlaubt war,
habe ich meine Ferien auf der Baustelle verbracht,
um halt auch meine Mopeds zu finanzieren,
mit denen dann wieder weiterer Unfug möglich war.
Also wir haben zum Beispiel bei Schneelagen im örtlichen Stadtpark
Skiringe hinterm Mofa betrieben mit einem Abschleppseil und solche Späße gemacht.
Und halt so die üblichen Dinge.
Welches ist die optimale Düse im Vergaser?
Wie dick darf der Krümmer werden und wie weit kann man ihn absägen?
Mit Ansaug- und Ablasskanälen.
Dabei bist du sauber geblieben?
Ja ich sage ja, wenn es sauber zu Hause wieder angekommen ist das Kind,
dann war was nicht in Ordnung.
Also das war dann doch nicht so oft?
Ja, eher selten.
Ja und ich sage mal vom also es gibt so eine Anekdote.
Einer meiner also meiner bewusster Erstkontakt mit Tieren war
meine Tante wohnte nicht weit weg
und es gab in Alt-Hamborn eine Einkaufszone, die Jägerstraße.
Ich sage mal so, im Kindergartenalter hat man sich damals ja schon getraut,
die Kinder alleine von A nach B laufen zu lassen.
Und ich weiß noch es war ein Wintertag und ich kam wohl irgendwie nicht zuhause an.
Und dann ging der Alarmruf los und man suchte das Kind.
Wo ist der Jochen?
Und dann fanden die mich halt wieder in dieser Fußgängerzone.
In der Linken hatte ich eine Sammeldose, in der Rechten ein Lama
Und es stellte sich halt heraus,
der also dieser Zirkusmitarbeiter, der da eben sammelnd mit dem Lama stand,
man sieht das ja heute noch manchmal, nicht?
Wenn auch nicht oft...
Jetzt demnächst wieder.
Im Winter immer gerne.
Ja, dem war halt furchtbar kalt
und ich stand halt staunend mit großen Augen vor diesem Tier
und dann hat er die Gelegenheit beim Schopfe ergriffen.
Und hat gesagt: "Hier Junge, mach du mal."
Und ich war stolz wie Bolle.
Funktioniert vielleicht auch besser das Sammeln mit so kleinen Kindern.
Ja, weißt ja also kleine Hunde funktionieren noch besser als Kinder habe ich gelernt.
Ach echt?
Oh ha.
Das sieht schon bald wieder ??? sozusagen.
Einfach einen Hund ans Lama binden und ab geht es.
Ja, das hat aber wieder eine Eigendynamik oder kann es zumindest kriegen.
Ja und ich bin dann,
also ich habe eine IT-Ausbildung gemacht damals bei Nixdorf Computer in Paderborn.
Die hat von 1988 bis 91 gedauert.
Eigentlich für den Kundendienst gedacht,
dass man mit Ersatzteilen halt durch die Kundschaft,
also ich habe mich eine Zeitlang mit den Aldis dieser Welt beschäftigt
und den Supermärkten und mein Rekord war glaube ich mal
neun Aldi-Kassen an einem Tag zu reparieren.
Quer durchs Ruhrgebiet, durch Essen, Mülheim, Oberhausen,
in der Gegend war ich unterwegs.
Bin nach also eigentlich schon während der Ausbildung
habe ich eine Vertriebsorientierung gewählt,
bin Anfang 1991 in den neuen Bundesländern nach Leipzig,
hab da den Sparkassen-Markt betreut.
Und ich weiß noch, die ersten Geldautomaten in Dresden aufgestellt.
Da gabs an den Geldautomaten Durchlaufzeiten von sechs Stunden bis man dran war.
Und diese Geduld dieser Menschen, die fand ich wirklich bewundernswert.
Das waren schon wilde Zeiten.
Mit C-Netz Autotelefon musste ich auch geduldig sein.
Bis zu zwei Stunden für ein Gespräch auf irgendeiner Autobahnbrücke verbringen.
Einen erhöhten Punkt finden, um genug empfangen zu haben.
Oh Gott, die dunklen Zeiten.
Ja, ja, das war schon ganz großartig.
Ja, dann bin ich irgendwann wieder
zurück in den Westen nach so etwa zwei drei Jahren
und bin dann eigentlich so durch die IT- Welt, wie sie sich damals entwickelte,
immer mehr in Richtung Software
und hab mich immer mehr in Richtung Vertrieb verhaftet,
bis ich dann so mit
etwa Mitte 30 also war ich so einer dieser ich nenne das immer
Obdachloser im Armani Anzug.
Also man hängt irgendwie an den Flughäfen ab
und fährt eigentlich im klimatisierten Auto von einer Tiefgarage in die nächste,
fährt in den Aufzug in den klimatisierten Büros, sieht kein Draußen mehr
und ich war damals glaube ich dreimal in London
und das Einzige was ich kannte, war das Marriott Hotel am Flughafen.
Und dann fängt man ernsthaft an, über den Sinn des Lebens nachzudenken.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Also dieser Duft der Hotel Bettwäsche da.
Also ich kenne Leute, die haben davon Ausschlag bekommen.
Also es ist einfach eine Welt, der ich dann zu entfliehen suchte
und hab dann halt eine Zeitlang im IT-Bereich ein Software-Unternehmen aufgebaut
und das ist dann irgendwann
eben auch wieder abgeschlossen gewesen diese Atmosphäre
und dann hab ich so vor etwa drei Jahren halt eben:
"Wow was machst du jetzt mit dem Rest deines Lebens?"
Hab ich mit einem Podcast angefangen
und kümmere mich seitdem zunächst mal um die Jagd.
Aber dann ist ja die Jagd jetzt auch nicht erst vor drei Jahren in dein Leben getreten.
Nein nein, die ist immer wieder,
also ich sage mal eigentlich vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter gefasst,
das ist eigentlich das Thema mit Leben und Tod und Fürsorge für Tiere.
Also die erste Anekdote mit dem Lama war ja noch unterhaltsam.
Wir hatten in der Familie später mal einen Rauhaardackel
und ich weiß noch wie halt, also meine Eltern hatten damals ein Haus
im Landkreis Cloppenburg gekauft
und für die Abwässer gab es so ein Drei-Kammern-Systemen nennt man es glaube ich.
Mittlerweile wird es gerade wieder verboten.
Aber auf jeden Fall war da gerade der Aushub dafür gemacht,
senkrechte Wände etwa zwei Meter tief
und unten in dieser Grube auf flitzte halt eine Maus rum
und unser Dackel lag oben an der Kante,
Kopf und Pfoten unten drüber und hatte fernsehen.
Erstmal dachten wir.
Der lag da stundenlang und beobachtete diese Maus,
wie sie versuchte da raus zukommen.
Und irgendwann hat dieser kleine Hund mit seinen kurzen Beinen
halt seinen gesamten Charakter in eine Tat verpackt und ist darunter gesprungen
Und die Maus hatte es hinter sich.
Ich meine da dem Hund konnte man natürlich einfach diese Passion auch ansehen.
Und ich meine natürlich auf der anderen Seite der Maus als Beute auch
die Not, die sie hatte.
Klar.
Aber da merkte man auf einmal, da ist irgendwas auf einer ganz tiefen Ebene
auf einem gemeinsamen Nenner miteinander angekommen.
Ja und dieser Hund,
der ist später halt irgendwie am Rücken erkrankt und war mehrfach in einer Klinik
und hatte einen kahl rasierten Rücken und dann haben die Sonden ins Rückenmark,
um da irgendwas herauszufinden und zu untersuchen.
Also ich erinnere mich nicht an Details.
Ich war da so 13/14 Jahre alt
und ab irgendeinem Zeitpunkt war einfach klar,
dass dem Hund nicht mehr zu helfen ist.
Und jetzt war einfach ein Punkt eingetreten,
also wo ich damals eigentlich schon gesagt, also gedacht und gesagt habe:
"Lass, erlöst das Tier."
Weil also dann ist der Tod halt einfach die bessere Option.
Und mein Vater war ein
zwar handwerklich sehr Korrekter mit einem rechten Winkel unterwegs,
aber halt eben auch sehr, der tat sich sehr schwer dieses Leben loszulassen
und diese Entscheidung zu treffen
und den Hund dann halt einschläfern zu lassen.
Ich weiß noch, dass ich da wirklich über
ja ich glaube über mehrere Wochen sogar halt wirklich:
"Echt ey, warum macht er das nicht?"
Also das fordert ja dann auch Mut und Entschlossenheit und eine Tatkraft,
wo man halt einfach man sagen muss:
"So, jetzt muss ich da drüber weg und dann muss ich es halt tun."
Also das war
schon etwas, was mich mitgenommen hat und
dann vergingen wieder ein paar Jahre und ich
also meine erste große Liebe war die Tochter eines Oberförster am Niederrhein.
Also ich war einige Zeit Anwärter auf die Position des Schwiegersohns in dieser Familie.
Okay.
Und ja, da war Jagd eben Bestandteil des Alltags.
Und da gab es eben auch einen sehr alten Hund, ein Deutsch-Drahthaar
Und eines Abends ging er halt mit dem Hund los und kam ohne Hund zurück.
Und das wurde in dieser Familie auch gar nicht groß groß besprochen, aber...
Also ging auf die Jagd und kam ohne Hund zurück oder.
Ja, ob er auf die Jagd ging oder nicht weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nur mit Hund los und ohne Hund zurück.
Und die diskrete Information hintenrum war halt eben,
dass er den Hund persönlich erlöst hat
Von seinem Alters...
Irdischen Dasein.
Also der hatte
ja einfach eine Altersstufe erreicht, wo klar war, wir reden über Tage vielleicht
wenige Wochen, aber nicht mehr über eine Lebensqualität.
Und ich erinnere mich eigentlich noch gut das hat mich
auch in einer gewissen Hinsicht befremdet.
Andererseits ist es aber natürlich
ein Stück Verantwortung, also wenn man einen Hund hat,
der zum Beispiel vom Tierarzt eine große Panik hat,
dann ist es eigentlich eine ja vielleicht auch
ein Dankeschön an dieses Tier, was einen über viele Jahre in oft kritischen,
abenteuerlichen Situationen begleitet hat,
wo man eine große Verlässlichkeit braucht
auch eine Art des Letzt Verneigens, dass man diese diese Last auf sich nimmt.
Es hat viele Aspekte und ich weiß,
das kann man auch sehr kritisch sehen.
Also habe ich damals ja auch selber, sehe es auch heute noch so.
Also ich sagen wir, wenn der Notstand so wäre, könnte ich es wahrscheinlich auch,
aber...
So oder so, es war so in diesem Moment.
Ja und ja gut das war jetzt so eben
Abitur, Bundeswehrzeit so bei mir die Größenordnung.
Ja und dann bin ich eben in diese IT-Karriere rein gerutscht
und dann war über Jahrzehnte halt Ruhe,
bis dann irgendwann mit Mitte 30 war es so:
"Was machst denn hier den ganzen Tag?"
Obdachloser im Armani Anzug eben.
Und: "Du kannst ja noch nicht mal ein Hund haben."
Also in dieses Leben passt halt einfach kein Hund hinein geht ja nicht.
Da habe ich gedacht:
"Was ist das für eine Existenz?"
Also wie abstrus ist denn das, dass man dieses Leben führt?
Also ich war damals auch durchaus wohlhabend, da war relativ viel Geld da.
Noch nicht mal so etwas ganz Einfaches geht und dann...
Da fehlt dir die Freiheit sozusagen.
Ja.
Also sich einfach mal authentisch mit
Wärme, Kälte empfinden, Wind im Gesicht spüren, Duft von
Boden und Holz und was auch immer
außerhalb dieser Kästchen die wir uns hier ja so
vermeintlich bequem...
Man will dann dreckig sein auch.
Ja, damit habe ich ja geübt viele Jahre lang.
Ja und der Hund,
den hab ich mir halt über Monate ausgesucht nach Rasse und wo ist der
Züchter und was will ich überhaupt damit machen
und eigentlich war es ein ganz einfaches Ziel.
Ich wollte den, egal in welcher Situation, ohne Leine bewegen können.
Ja, was ist da die Anforderung an so einen Hund?
Oder ist das mehr eine Anforderung an einen selbst?
Beides.
Also es gibt, also Hunde sind ja eigentlich eine Kulturleistung des Menschen.
Man hat Wildtiere zu seinen eigenen Zwecken selektiert
und so lange miteinander verpaart bis die das...
Diese Eigenschaften hatten, die man haben möchte.
Was man möchte.
Und ich wollte erst einmal einen guten Begleiter haben
mit einem guten Gehorsam und das war
ehrlich gesagt eine Kleinigkeit.
Wenn man sich ein bisschen rein denkt in diese Welt und wie
konditioniere ich ein Kommando, wie verfestige ich es und wie sichere ich es hinterher
wieder ab mit Konflikten.
Also wenn man diese Prinzipien einmal verstanden hat,
dann ist es gar nicht so wahnsinnig schwer.
Das war aber etwas, was du schon kanntest
im Prinzip aus der Hundezeit vorher oder es war etwas...
Nee, das hab ich dann gelernt.
Indem du jetzt ein Hundetraining gemacht hast
oder ist es jetzt nur eine Frage, welche Hunderasse geht man überhaupt erst an oder...
Es ist eine Kombination aus beidem.
Also ich habe einen Labrador Retriever, eine Hündin, die ist heute elf Jahre alt
und ich könnte,
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel das andere Extrem den Deutschen Jagd Terrier nehme,
der ist halt einfach darauf selektiert alleine klarzukommen.
Also ich kenne auch Leute, da gehen die frei bei Fuß,
aber das ist eine unglaubliche Arbeitsleistung, die sehr viel mehr
Einsatz und Kenntnisse
natürlich auch erfordert, als ein Hund, der ohnehin darauf selektiert ist,
den ständigen Kontakt zu seinem
Menschen zu halten und Kooperation quasi in die Gene transportiert bekommen hat.
Ja und in der Ausbildung dieses Hundes
stand ich halt irgendwann mal vor der Frage, will ich
einen Jagdhund oder einen Sporthund.
Was war denn jetzt nochmal genau die Entscheidung für den Retriever?
Also was, welche Eigenschaft bringt
diese Hunderasse so mit, dass das für dich jetzt interessant war
oder warum hat das deine Kriterien erfüllt?
Eine gute Alltagstauglichkeit, weil die erstmal die bellen nicht viel.
Also ich wohnte damals in einer Mietwohnung in der zweiten Etage.
Also da ist jetzt kein Terror in der Nachbarschaft zu erwarten.
Die sind leichtführig eher, trotzdem verbunden mit einer Arbeitspassion.
Also die Rasse hat einen sogenannten will to please, also einen Wunsch
in diesem Umfeldihrem Menschen zu gefallen.
Das ist ein Rassemerkmal.
Ja gut, dann gibt es ein paar Äußerlichkeiten
wie Fellpflege also ein Golden Retriever hat
ein relativ langes Fell wo natürlich alles mögliche drin hängenbleibt.
Das hat man beim Labrador nicht so sehr, also man muss da keine Zöpfe flechten.
Da bin ich sowieso nicht so gut
Ja also kurzhaarig und so ja.
Solche Dinge eben.
Ja und ich hatte mir damals
sogenannte Working Test, also das sind ein Apportier-Spezialisten,
eigentlich Hunde, die aus England kommen,
das ist auch ein Unterschied im Hundewesen
zwischen England und Deutschland.
Die Engländer haben gerne einen Spezialisten der eine Sache richtig gut kann.
Also ein Pointer ist ein Vorstehhund, ein Retriever ist ein Apportier-Spezialist
in diesem Umfeld also immer ein Experte für irgendwas oder ein
Spaniel ist ein Buschierhund eigentlich der sehr kurz
und sehr geländegängig durch die Büsche geht,
um irgendwelches Wild da aufzustöbern.
Und der Deutsche hat gerne den sogenannten Vollgebrauchshund.
Der kann alles ein bisschen, aber nichts richtig sag ich dann immer.
Also der Schäferhund oder der Terrier...?
Nee, das ist zum Beispiel, also der Standard,
den die meisten haben, ist ein Deutsch-Drahthaar.
Der apportiert ganz leidlich.
Der hat eine ziemlich ausgeprägte Raubwildschärfe,
also die haben auch immer so Bandbreiten innerhalb
der Rasse, der ist relativ schnell der ist wasserfreudig,
der arbeitet auch noch ganz gut als Vorstehhund
in der Quersuche unter der Flinte, also du merkst, es kommen ganz viel...
Kommen geile Wörter.
Was ist denn eine Raubwildschärfe?
Naja, ich habe jetzt meine zum Beispiel,
wenn ich einen Hasen bekommt, also der jetzt verletzt ist,
ich brauche den Hund vor allem aus Tierschutzgründen, um einem verletzten Tier auch
wirklich habhaft zu werden,
dann tanzt die so lange drumrum, bis die denen am Rücken
packen kann, damit sie nicht verdroschen wird.
Der Retriever?
Der Retriever.
Also das ist, das nennt man Bildschärfe.
Also Schärfe hört sich jetzt immer sehr brutal an.
Ich mein, ist es ja im gewissen Umfang auch, aber der muss natürlich den Willen haben,
das Wild zu kriegen und
wieder nach Hause zu bringen und nicht damit durchzubrennen
und eine Raubwildschärfe ist, Raubwild
wie ein Fuchs zum Beispiel oder ein Marder ist natürlich noch einmal wehrhaft und die
müssen natürlich mit dieser...
Also so eine Konfliktbereitschaft.
Eine Konfliktbereitschaft, also das sind...
Weil du hast ja jetzt gerade über ein Drahthaar und bei diesen
Universal-Rassen der Deutschen..
Also der Deutsche hält sich also sozusagen gerne so einen All-in-One-
Hund und die Brieten spezialisieren sich mehr
und du bist dann quasi mit dem Retriever auf ein Spezialist für Retrieving sozusagen.
Der Name ist Programm.
Kann gut Beute bringen.
Okay.
Also wenn man noch ein bisschen einsteigen wollen
eigentlich drei Disziplinen, das ist das
sogenannte Markieren,
also die merken sich Fallstellen,
laufen da hin und bringen es nach Hause.
Die Freiverlorensuche.
Also hier ist ein Gebiet,
geh hinein und finde irgend alles, was da drin ist und die Königsdisziplin
ist das sogenannte Einweisen auf Blinds, wie man sie denn nennt.
Also ich als Mensch weiß
die Fallstelle, der Hund hat nichts gesehen
und ich kann den Hund im Grunde mit Handzeichen und
Pfeifensignalen zu dieser Fallstelle hinlenken zumindest in die Witterung,
sodass er dann halt am Ende eben Erfolg hat.
So fernsteuerungsmäßig.
So links, rechts, weiter hinten.
Ja ich nenne es lieber Kooperationen aber...
Ja, okay.
Also dieses, das ist eine Eigenart, die in der Ausbildung
sehr viel Mühe braucht, weil ich schick einen Hund
hundert Mal auf in die Richtung der Hand
und der Hund muss immer Erfolg haben
und dann läuft er beim hundert-ersten Mal weißte halt wenn
der nicht schickt, ist da auch was.
Also deshalb ist Fernsteuerung so ein bisschen despektierlich dem Hund gegenüber.
Ich empfinde es eher als eine sehr hohe Stufe der Kooperation mit dem Tier
und das istauch das Beglückende übrigens
mit Hunden.
Diese Symbiose die daraus entsteht
Ja, macht man sich ja selten klar,
hast du ja schon angedeutet, dass sozusagen alle Hunde heutzutage eigentlich mal Wölfe waren
und dass das alles so hervorgegangen ist aus so einzelnen Wölfen, die in irgendeiner Form sich gesagt haben:
"Naja ist ja hier gar nicht so schlecht beim Menschen, vielleicht ergibt sich da was draus."
Und daraus hat sich ja im Prinzip diese ganze Hundewelt eigentlich erst erichtet und ist eigentlich auch
das beste Beispiel für wie der Mensch sich so quasi der Natur auch, wie er sich die Natur angeeignet hat
und zwar jenseits der reinen Landnahme, sondern eben auch an der Stelle eben auch
diese Kooperation mit den Lebewesen, die ja bis hin in ihre Evolution eingreifen.
Wenn man sich heutzutage die Unterschiedlichkeit von Hunden anschaut,
ich meine von so kleinen Pinschern und Chihuahuas bis hin zu Deutschen Doggen, da fragt man sich halt,
wie kann denn das überhaupt einen gemeinsamen Stamm haben?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das biologisch tatsächlich so ist,
aber ich glaube so ja unterschiedliche Wölfe wird es gegeben haben,
aber die werden sich nicht so sehr unterschieden haben, wie das Hunde heute tun, oder?
Also ja die haben, also wenn man, also ich bin jetzt kein Experte im Thema,
aber wenn man sich mal die
Kooperation eines Wolfsrudels anguckt, dann findet man zum Beispiel dieses Einrudeln.
Also die arbeiten ja auch im Team miteinander
und wenn die jetzt auf eine Herde Tiere stoßen,
dann rudeln die die ein.
Das ist zum Beispiel eine Eigenschaft, daraus hat man die Hütehunde entwickelt.
Die tun ja nichts anderes als das.
Also ein Hütehund ist im Grunde auch ein Jagdhund, wo man
genau diese eine Eigenschaft
herausgezüchtet hat, zusätzlich eine Beißhemmung gefördert
hat, weil man will ja nicht, dass die Tiere verletzt werden und das so in den Dienst des
Menschen gestellt.
Oder ganz krass ist die Nasenleistung.
Also das ist eigentlich für mich nach wie vor immer noch.
Da kriege ich Gänsehaut und falle auf die Knie.
Also ich erinnere mich wie die ersten Arbeiten mit Wild,
also das war, das muss ich jetzt mal akustisch beschreiben.
Eine Situation, also zu einem Apportieren schicken,
aber über einen Hügel hinweg und dann wurde eine Ente glaube ich geworfen.
Die wurde aber wieder eingesammelt und dahinter war aber
eine sogenannte Schleppe,
also eine Schleifspur mit einer Ente,
die dann 50 Meter weiter in irgendeinem Gebüsch gelegt wurde.
Also eine tote Ente.
Eine tote Ente.
So, der Hund sah die Ente fliegen, okay da ist was. ja und dann schicke ich
Also man hat die hochgeworfen sozusagen, ja.
Und dann schicke ich ihn los
und jetzt kommt der irgendwo auf diese Spur.
So und der Hund braucht keinen Meter, um die Fluchtrichtung
zu identifizieren und in die richtige Richtung loszulaufen.
Weil hätten ja beide Richtungen sein können.
Ja und jetzt versuchst du das mal mit deiner Nase
Ich hätte schon Schwierigkeiten mit der Schleppspur.
Also die überhaupt zu finden natürlich.
Und ich sag mal diese, wenn man sich aber erst mal wieder klarmacht, dass
die Chance,
die eigene Existenz ja im Grunde fortsetzen zu dürfen durch die Nahrungsaufnahme fiftyfifty
ist, je nachdem welche Richtung ich nehme.
Ist das ein überlebenswichtiges Ding.
Wenn man es jetzt nochmal auf die andere Ebene, die Anzahl der Riechzellen,
die wir Menschen so haben, die liegt glaube ich irgendwie bei 200000
so und ein Hund hat weit über 2 Millionen Riechzellen und einen ganzen Gehirnbereich,
der den auswertet.
Also eine ganz andere Auflösung wie wir in der Computerwelt sagen.
Diese Wahrnehmung der Welt ist also
eine, die im Wesentlichen durch die Nase geprägt ist,
während wir ja eher optische gesteuerte Lebewesen sind.
Und die Spitze dabei sind eben
also Schweißhunde, also Fährtenhunde.
Der Jäger nennt Blut, was außerhalb des Körpers ist Schweiß,
also feinere Auflösung.
Und man hat, also das Härteste, was ich mal gehört habe,
war eine Nachsuche, die 30 Stunden gedauert hat.
Im Hochgebirge.
Der Hund war über Nacht weg.
Also man geht im Grunde blind hinter dem Hund her
und muss an den Reaktionen des Hundes
ablesen, ob er noch auf der Fährte ist
oder sich von irgendeiner kreuzenden Verleihtspur hat ablenken lasst.
Mancher zuckt dann mit den Ohren, der andere wedelt mal aufgeregt mit der Rute.
Also das sind so Hundeführerkünste und
hat teilweise auch überhaupt gar keine Schweißspur mehr.
Also ein Hund, eine Wunde macht auch irgendwann wieder zu bei einem
verletzten Tier
und dann sind die in Fluchtverhalten ja auch noch, so die kreuzen teilweise
die Rudel der eigenen Art,
um halt eben ihre eigene Spur zu verwischen und so ein Hund ist in der
Lage diese individuellen Trittsiegel
bis zu 48 Stunden oder manche, ich habe auch schon
längeres gehört, nachzuarbeiten.
Und ich sage mal diese Nachsuche, von der ich da jetzt
gerade sprach, die hat 30 Stunden gedauert
am Ende und der gleiche Hund, der dann noch nachts weg
war, den fand man morgens,
die haben am Anschluss also da, wo das Tier getroffen wurde, an dem Örtchen,
den Mantel des Hundeführer hingelegt
und die fanden den Hund morgens eingeschmolzen in
den Schnee wieder und der gleiche Hund ist dann noch die Fährte weiter,
wollte unbedingt.
Also das sind,
das ist so die Dimension der Erlebnisse und diese Kooperationen mit Mensch und Tier,
die also die einfach irre ist.
Jetzt hast du dich für diesen Labrador entschieden, für diesen Retriever
aus zahlreichen Gründen, die wir jetzt schon angerissen haben,
aber es war jetzt eigentlich gar nicht deine eigentliche Intension,
damit in die Jagd einzusteigen, oder?
In dem Moment nicht, nein.
Sondern das war sozusagen einfach nur so eine Qualität, die du gesucht hast,
weil du einfach Quais nach dem richtigen Partner geschaut hast,
der sozusagen auch in dein Leben passt.
Ist ja sozusagen, es ist ja im wahrten Sinne des Wortes Partnerwahl hier an der Stelle
Bist dann sozusagen dein eigenes Social-Dateing-Network da,
Hunde-Dateing-Network, eingestiegen.
Ja, Tinder für Köter.
Okay.
Und das war dann auch ganz erfolgreich.
Ja.
Also konkret, ich hatte irgendwann,
dieser Apportiert-Sport wird halt mit den Hunden also mit
Wettbewerben und Working-Tests betrieben auch auf einer internationalen Ebene.
Und man will von einem Hund, wenn ich
die Richtung gebe beim Einweisen, dass der genau
dahin läuft, wo ich will und genau auf mein Pfeifensignal seine Arbeit tut.
Läuft so ein Hund über eine Lebendfährte von irgendwas anderem,
dann soll der trotzdem die Richtung behalten und bei
einem Jagdhund möchte ich halt, dass der die Lebendfährte arbeitet, weil das Tote liegt
später immer noch da und das Lebende muss ich sofort haben.
Und das war für mich dann eigentlich der Punkt, wo ich gesagt habe, was will ich überhaupt mit dem hin?
Wo will ich mit ihr hin?
So und dann begab es sich ebenso,
dass eine Schwester meines Hundes, also aus dem gleichen
Wurf, bei einem Grafen in Münsterland zuhause war und ich hatte dem halt mal also bei diesen
Welpenprägungs- und Ausbildungsgeschichte irgendwann mal angesprochen:
"Sagen Sie, ist das eigentlich okay, wenn ich bei Ihnen mal bei so einer Jagd mitgehe?"
Und der sah halt auch, dass ich mir viel Mühe mit der
Ausbildung gab und dann nahm der alter ??? (Mehr):
"Ja, kommen Sie mal vorbei."
Da war ich dann so zwei, drei Mal, bin als
Hundeführer mitgegangen und es war insofern auch sehr beeindruckend, weil diese
Gesellschaftsjagden auf dem Land eine soziale Funktion auch haben.
Also da rückt das Dorf zusammen, da kommt die Familie wieder zusammen.
Diese Jagdgesellschaft zog durch die Lande
und da war ein Familiengrab im Wald da hielt
dann alles an und dann wurde halt auf dem Jagdhorn angeblasen,
was so eine gewisse Feierlichkeit hat.
Also für mich wurde quasi greifbar
diese Verbindung zu der Erde auf der sie leben und von
der sie auch leben
und Teil dieses Geschehens zu sein, hat auf mich halt Anziehungskraft ausgeübt.
Ich fand das...
Wie groß war diese Jagdgesellschaft?
Wie groß ist so eine Gesellschaft, wenn sie auf Jagd...
20 bis 30 Leute
Die alle aber auch eine spezifische Funktion erfüllen dann in dieser Gruppe?
Bei den Niederwildjagten ist es,
also es gibt Treiber, das sind
also manchmal die Jugendlichen oder die Frauen, die gehen halt durch in Reihen und
treiben auf, dann werden Schützenstände halt auf der anderen Seite...
Und bei Niederwild heißt?
Niederwild ist ab Reh abwärts.
Im Grunde alles.
Also Reh, inklusive alles, was kleiner ist.
Das ist ein Begriff, der kommt
noch aus dieser alten Adelsgeschichte.
Ja, also keine Elefanten.
Nee nee, keine Elefanten.
Obwohl ein Freund von mir hat in Holland mal ein freilaufendes Känguru gesehen.
Das wollte ihm auch keiner glauben.
Gibt ja mittlerweile alles
Okay und du hast dann da auch gleiche eine Funktion übernommen.
Und dann Hundeführer heißt?
Hundeführer heißt, ich stand mit dem Hund bei einem Schützen und...
Also dann schon mit deinem Hund?
Mit meinem Hund ja.
Und wenn der was erlegt hat,
hab ich halt den Hund arbeiten lassen.
Ja, okay.
Der hat sich da auch gleich drauf eingelassen?
Er hat sich auch gleich drauf...
Mein Hund fand das... dafür ist sie gemacht.
Also muss man sich ja klar machen.
Dafür sind die gemacht.
Das ist ja auch oft einer der
Konflikte wenn der Mensch denkt, wir gehen spazieren,
denkt der Hund wir gehen jagen.
Und schon kriegen die kein Gespräch zustande.
Ja, es ist so.
Ja gut und in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang,
war dann, irgendwann hab ich halt dem alten Grafen, was sowieso ein Filu war,
also dem haben sie mal das Knie punktiert
und dann sagt der Arzt: "Ja da kommt Blut", und dann sagt er:
"Es kann gar nicht sein, mein Blut ist blau."
Solche Späße riss der dann auch noch.
Ja und dann sagte ich: "Ich liebäugel damit, die Jägerprüfung zu machen."
Und dann ging er an seinen Waffenschrank, drückte mir eine Flinte in die Hand.
Und sagt: "Hier nehmen Sie mit.
Können Sie Anschlagübungen machen."
Und ich: "Nein!"
Waffenrecht, also das das hochgradig verboten war, war mir ja klar.
Ja.
Und jetzt hab ich zwar was gesagt, aber hoffentlich nimmt mich keiner dafür hoch.
Also dieses Stück Eisen,
also Widerstand war zwecklos, hab ich mit nach Hause genommen
und dann hatte ich natürlich höchsten
Druck das Ganze zu legalisieren.
Ja dann war es um mich geschehen.
Okay, das ging ja schnell.
Ja das ist jetzt so acht, neun Jahre her.
Aber das war auch das erste Mal überhaupt,
dass du an die Jagd rangekommen bist?
Das hattest du jetzt so vorher eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Außer dem Oberförster sozusagen.
Ja genau, also zu der Zeit war ich mal einmal bei so einer Gesellschaftsjagd mit
und dann, also wie man so ist um die 18.
Echter Kerl, aber nichts anmerken lassen und in Wirklichkeit die Hosen voll.
Irgendjemand hat den Hasen erlegt und im Vorbeigehen:
"Hier häng ihn mal an den Treiberwagen!"
Und dann hatte ich diesen noch körperwarmen Hasen in der Hand
und ich weiß nicht.
Der fühlte sich ja noch lebendig an.
Der war aber tot.
Ja.
Und dann umwickelt man halt die Läufe mit Draht und hängt die an den Wagen.
Und ich: "Ich tu dem doch weh."
Diesen unmittelbaren Kontakt mit Tod, den hatte ich da das erste Mal.
Hat mich auch bis heute nicht so richtig verlassen,
aber ich glaube ein guter Jäger, den verlässt das auch nie wirklich.
Können wir doch vielleicht mal so ein bisschen,
vielleicht spulen wir einmal ein bisschen zurück,
um auch diese ganze Jagdgeschichte, wie sie sich heute darstellt,
auch besser in den Kontext setzen zu können.
Jetzt ist ja der Mensch im Prinzip auch,
ja, wie sagt man immer so schön,
als Sammler und Jäger gestartet.
Wo wir jetzt wirklich gestartet sind,
das ist in gewisser Hinsicht immer noch Objekt der Forschung.
Und wenn man sich sozusagen unsere ganzen Vorfahren anschaut,
aber es ist halt schon klar, der Homo sapiens hat halt irgendwann im Wesentlichen
seine Ernährung dadurch geleistet, indem er halt Früchte,
oder was auch immer sich zum Essen anbot, einfach eingesammelt hat,
oder eben andere Tiere gejagt hat.
Weiß nicht, hast du da so ein bisschen Einblick?
Ich meine heutzutage ist ja Jagd,
und darüber wollen wir ja eigentlich auch reden, kultiviert.
Hat sich über Jahrhunderte entwickelt,
hat eine bestimmte Ausprägung,
hat auch eine bestimmte Funktion, auf die wir sicherlich kommen werden,
aber am Anfang war es ja einfach so das nackte Überleben, sozusagen.
Also der Mensch war ein Tier unter vielen
und hat gejagt und geraubt wie viele andere Tiere auch,
die so eine Lebensform ausgeprägt haben
und irgendwann hat er es dann auch mal wieder sein lassen
oder zumindest sich um andere Nahrungsoptionen...
Also die ältesten Erkenntnisse, die mir bekannt sind,
also an möge mich jetzt wirklich nicht auf Jahreszahlen oder
Quellen so ganz wahnsinnig nageln.
Die Menschheit hat ja ihren Ursprung in Afrika
und ich sage mal vor drei Millionen Jahren,
also um jetzt mal
eine Größenordnung in den Raum zu rufen, war es in der Tat so, dass diese
Urart, aus der wir entstammen, im Wesentlichen vegetarisch gelebt hat.
Und dann gab es damals wohl irgendeine Klimaverschiebung,
die dazu geführt hat, dass
Afrika im Kern austrocknete, also sich mehr
in Savannenlandschaft in offene Landschaften
umgewandelt hat und da gab es dann wohl einen Split in der Evolution, dass ein Strang
versucht hat sich weiter vegetarisch zu ernähren
und der andere angefangen hat mit Jagdfähigkeiten.
Was man da herausgefunden hat, ist, dass unsere
Konstellation, also wenn man sich vielleicht nochmal
vorstellt, ein Schimpanse versucht einen Gegenstand zu werfen, dann sieht das
ziemlich tapsig und lächerlich aus.
Und wir Menschen haben eine ganz große Fähigkeit,
Gegenstände sehr zielgerichtet zu werfen.
Daraus wurde dann halt eben Speerwerfen.
Also ich kann halt
auf eine relativ große Distanz ein Tier mit einem Werkzeug, wie einem Speer halt eben zur Strecke bringen.
Erlegen.
Zusätzlich haben wir halt die Möglichkeit, wenn es um den Lauf eines Marathons geht,
ein Pferd tot zu laufen.
Wir können länger laufen als jedes andere Tier.
Wir haben unglaubliche Ausdauerfähigkeiten.
So und die Kombination aus dieser Hetzjagd,
die möglich war, plus dem finalen Erlegen auch aus einer gewissen Distanz,
hat dann dazu geführt, dass dieser Zweig sich wohl evolutionär verfestigt hat,
die proteinhaltige Ernährung hat dafür gesorgt,
dass in einem Zeitraum, den ich jetzt nicht ganz genau weiß,
aber das hat man so an Funden nachvollzogen, das Gehirnvolumen von 600
Kubikzentimeter auf 1400 Kubikzentimeter angewachsen ist.
Und man hat die ersten sozialen Fähigkeiten so wirklich entwickelt.
Also über etwas ganz Einfaches hinaus, weil man halt eben
kooperativ besser jagen konnte, als für sich alleine.
Also ein Wild umschlagen unter Ausnutzung der Windrichtung,
dass meine Witterung da nicht ankommt,
den Weg verstellen und das dann halt im Team zu organisieren
oder auch mit in Kooperation größere Tiere zu erlegen.
Also es gibt ja selbst Mammuts, die von Menschen erlegt wurden,
also wo einfach die vielen Mücken am Ende das Tod des Mammuts waren.
Also im Nahkampf dann am Ende zumindest.
Die Mücken? Achso die Menschen im Vergleich...
20 Jäger mit ihren Speeren drauf einwirken,
irgendwann gibt's halt auf das Mammut.
Also es ist natürlich alles noch sehr archaisch, aber
über diese Tätigkeit hat die Physiognomie
sagt man glaube ich, also unsere körperlichen Fähigkeiten ist
zum Beispiel, dass unser Schultergelenk eins ist,
was halt eben diese Ausholbewegung des Werfens ganz gut kann.
Das kann ein Primat nicht sonst.
Wir haben eine Möglichkeit über die Drehung der Hüfte eine Spannung aufzubauen,
die dieseSchwungbewegung des Werfens halt
unterstützt und darüber halt eine große Zielgenauigkeit hinbekommen.
Nun, das waren ja im Grunde so,
also ich meine Jagen ist eigentlich der älteste Hacker-Sport der Welt, wenn man so will.
Also ich muss ja ein Verständnis für ein Lebenssystem meiner Zielwildart finden,
ich muss
eine Vorstellung davon haben, um dann an der richtigen Stelle gezielt reinzukommen.
Also auf welchem Weg laufen sie zum Wasser?
Wovon ernähren die sich, wie sind denn die Wanderrouten mit den Jahreszeiten?
Also ganz...
Zu welchen Tageszeiten tauchen die überhaupt wo auf.
Also es erfordert ja eine...
Große Analysefähigkeit erst mal auch.
Ja und auch eine Empathie.
Ich muss mich in die Welt wirklich rein fühlen.
Also das ist ja auch was,
was jagt so unglaublich interessant macht.
Also es ist wirklich ein System Verständnis kriegen,
sich da rein fühlen darüber auch eine
Bindung aufbauen, also manchmal sogar eine persönliche Bindung,
um dann aber wieder in einer
Geistesleistung oben drüber zu gehen und Unvermeidliches zu
tun, weil ich sehe ja sonst selbst auch wieder dahinscheide.
Also ich, meine eigene Existenz hängt ja zumindest unter diesen urtümlichen Bedingungen
ganz primär davon ab und auch das meiner Sippe.
Ja und so entwickelte sich das dann weiter,
also Pfeil und Bogen ist ja eigentlich nichts weiter, als
die nächste, also enhanced Speere sozusagen.
Ja also Speer 2.0..
Und ja dann hatte man letztendlich ein Alltag,
wenn man sich da mal rein denkt, also so stelle ich
ihn mir vor, dass ich mit meiner kleinen Sippe und den Dingen, die ich so tragen konnte
letztendlich den Wildtieren hinterher gezogen bin und deren ständiger Begleiter war,
weil sie ja eben auch meine Nahrungsgrundlage darstellten.
Zusätzlich zu den Dingen, die man natürlich so gesammelt und konsumiert hat.
Verstehe. Das hat dann sozusagen
auch diese Wanderschaft noch einmal enorm befeuert.
Ja, so verstehe ich es zumindest.
Ja, weil man muss halt quasi mit den Herden mitziehen
und die Herden ziehen halt mit dem Wetterverlauf
und dann ist man davon halt auch abhängig.
Klar, wenn man immer im gleichen Ort bleibt, dann ist halt nichts.
Ja und dann gab's einen Punkt in der Geschichte, der
war so in etwa vor 10 000 Jahren, also
ist noch gar nicht wahnsinnig lange her,
da kam irgendjemand auf die Idee und hat gesagt da
nehmen wir doch mal so einen Samen von der Pflanze und stecken den mal
in ein Stück Erde was
eigens zu dem Zweck freigelegt wurde.
Und da war die Landwirtschaft geboren
Das ist dann so
vor allem Nahost, Syrien.
Das sind so die Geburtsstätten der Landwirtschaft gewesen.
Euphrat, Tigris – die Region.
Also wahrscheinlich auch in Verbindung mit der Viehwirtschaft,
wo man irgendwann gelernt hätte
ich kann halt Wildtiere einfangen und ich kann die gezielt miteinander verpaaren,
dass die Dinge besser können, die ich brauche als Mensch.
So und jetzt hatte die Jagd auf einmal eine Zusatzfunktion.
Also vorher reine Nahrungsbeschaffung
und jetzt musste ich auf einmal meine
ersten kulturellen Leistungen gegen wilden Einfluss verteidigen.
Also habe ich mir einen Acker angeeignet,
mit dem Ziel da eine spezielle Frucht drauf zu entwickeln.
Dann möchte ich eben zum Beispiel nicht mehr, dass meine Wildschweine
wie frei draußen herumlaufen,
in diesen Acker reingehen, mir umdrehen
und mir meine Nahrungsgrundlage kaputt machen.
Und ich möchte auch keine wilden Einkreuzung mehr haben,
weil meine Zuchtziele damit
natürlich konterkariert werden.
Also war Jagd auf einmal auch Verteidigung.
Und letztendlich glaube ich damit, also so verstehe ich es, dieses
Landwirtschaft betreiben und Vieh züchten,
war ja im Grunde das, was sesshaft werden überhaupt
erst wirklich möglich machte.
Genau, weil man eben nicht mehr den Herden hinterher ziehen musste
und auch durch Vorratsanlegung et cetera
und dann eben auch die fortgeschrittenen Nahrungsbehandlungen,
sprich Mehl, Brot und Bier.
An der Stelle verweise ich auch nochmal an unseren wunderbaren CRE
zum Thema Bier.
Da kommen wir an dieser Stelle auch auf eine interessante Art und Weise vorbeigeschrammt.
Ja genau, so und dann wurde man halt unabhängiger von den Jahreszeiten,
unabhängiger auch von der Wanderung
und konnte halt irgendwie bleiben.
Meinst Jagd ist dann sozusagen mehr zur Verteidigung für
zur Erzielung der Zucht Ziele geworden.
Aber ich meine diesen Jagdaspekt, den gab's natürlich auch immer noch.
Ja also ich,
also mehr würde ich nicht sagen.
Auch.
Also es war einfach eine Zusatzfunktion und also gewichten will ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Es war nur, auf einmal war es so, ist übrigens auch bis heute so.
Ist nach wie vor eine Aufgabe, die da mit reinfällt.
Und die Hunde sind ja dann im Prinzip auch in diesem Zeitraum gekommen.
Habe gerade nochmal nachgeschlagen, also so richtig gut...
Es scheint wohl auch sehr umstritten zu sein,
wann der Hund wirklich dazu kam,
aber das scheint über einen sehr langen Zeitraum,
graduell stattgefunden zu haben.
Ja wahrscheinlich auch pendelt,
also wie die Kulturen auch gerade drauf eingeschossen waren.
Also da bist du jetzt wahrscheinlich mit deiner Netzrecherche schlauer als ich.
Ja, ich lese mir das jetzt hier nicht komplett durch.
Das ist eine Menge, was man hier erzählen kann zu Canis lupus so,
aber irgendwo zwischen 15.000 und 100.000 Jahren.
Also ist wirklich schon etwas unscharf definiert.
Ein langer Begleiter.
Und die sind auch extrem pfiffig sich in unserer Gemüt zu schleichen.
Da sind die außerordentlich begabt.
Also jetzt waren wir, also im Grunde ging da ja dann auch so die
Basis los für unsere Arbeitsteilung.
Also mach du halt den Acker, ich Bau dir einen Pflug.
Gib mir das Korn, ich Mahl dir das Mehl.
Gib mir das Mehl, ich back dir das Brot.
Also da fing er im Grunde an, sich die ganzen Aufgaben einfach zu teilen.
Beziehungsweise, auch die Jagd wurde sozusagen auch zu einer Spezialaufgabe,
die sich dann eben Leute sozusagen gewidmet haben,
die sich darauf konzentriert haben
und die dann halt das Fleisch rangebracht haben.
Genau und ich sag mal die Reinrassigkeit löste sich wahrscheinlich auch.
Also reine Jäger
gabs dann immer weniger.
Es gab halt dann immer mehr Leute, die auch zur Jagd gingen
aus mehr oder weniger schönen Gründen.
Also ist heute noch nicht lustig
bei Kälte auf Wildschweine zu lauern nicht unbedingt immer.
Weil?
Weil es kalt ist.
Windig und nass und diese Dinge.
Die Jagd hatte aber eigentlich ja ich denke schon fast immer und
hat sich auch lange gehalten so eine, ja so eine
Funktion im Erwachsenwerden.
Also das erste Mal mit auf die Jagd zu dürfen
und das erste Mal ein Tier zu erlegen war halt in
vielen Ur-Religionen natürlich einfach ein Schritt des Erwachsenwerdens.
Da wurde man dann halt eben überführt und ist ja übrigens auch viele Völker haben ja
irgendwie sich das Leben nach dem Tod als die ewigen Jagdgründe vorgestellt.
Also so schlimm kann es dann immer nicht sein.
Interessanter Punkt.
Da habe ich so nie darüber nachgedacht.
Also stammt sicherlich aus diesen Zeiten und ich meine, wenn man so im Altertum, griechische/
römische Mythologie, da gab's ja die Göttin der Jagd, die Diana,
eine Frau und bei den Griechen
gab's Artemis, auch Göttin der Jagd auch ein Mädchen, auch eine Frau.
Also auch ganz spannend.
Also ich bin dem noch nicht so richtig nachgegangen, aber
komischerweise wurde die Bejagung,
also Jagd ja damals eben Frauen zugeteilt auch als Hüterin der Wildtiere.
Also so eine Funktion war auch was drin.
Interessant.
Auch noch nicht darüber nachgedacht.
Man sagt ja Mutter Natur
In Deutschland. Ist das sonst auch immer so?
Ich meine, wir sagen auch "die Sonne",
aber da sind die anderen auch nicht... da gehen die anderen ja auch nicht mit.
Also Weiblichkeit ist ja etwas, immer als etwas behütendes verstanden worden.
Und die Ressourcen, von denen man lebt, galt es halt auch immer zu behüten.
Die waren halt wichtig.
Was man ja in so zum Beispiel in Indianer-Kulturen
auch in starker Ausprägung gefunden hat, dass sozusagen dieses...
die Bejagung immer auch einher ging so mit einer Wertschätzung.
Also wo dann sozusagen das Gejagte, wo man sich dann,
ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie die Riten so abliefen,
aber es gab dann halt so Dankes-Zeremonien et cetera,
so eine Verbundenheit
und halt auch generell in der indianischen Kultur halt
auch diese Vorstellung, dass das alles in Balance bleiben muss.
Was bei uns...
Glaube ich allerdings nicht, weil...
Ist das Mythos? Ist das Winnetou oder?
Also Gleichgewicht und Einheit ist so eine
also Natur ist ein ständiger Kampf,
ein ständiges Werden und Vergehen, ein Geben und Nehmen
und da gibt es kein Gleichgewicht,
weil wenn es ein Gleichgewicht gäbe, hätte ja die Entwicklung aufgehört.
Ja, ist richtig.
Also da gäbe es ja keinen,
keine neuen Arten und kein Aussterben von alten Arten.
Dieses Ganze nach vorne ist einfach ein eine Dynamik.
Die bis heute anhält.
Also deshalb ist dieser Begriff des Gleichgewichtes auch einer, der dem
eine Statik andiktiert,
die dem nicht gerecht wird.
Aber bleiben wir doch mal beim Altertum und den Göttinnen.
Ja, das ist der Punkt wo ich am wenigsten drüber weiß,
aber mach mal.
Wir können ja auch von da weiterziehen.
Aber es hat so auch auf jeden Fall
– gut, überrascht jetzt auch nicht sonderlich –
aber es hat da sozusagen auch göttlichen Status gehabt.
Es handelte sich auf jeden Fall um einen Bereich,
der es zumindest wert war, dass man da mal Götter zuweist.
Nicht nicht ganz unerheblich.
Überhaupt spielt sich ja dann die Jagd,
vor allem wie wir sie heute kennen, halt in zunehmendem Maße
hier so in unserem Festland Europa ab.
Der Mensch zog ja weiter nach Norden,
die klimatischen Bedingungen haben sich geändert.
Nach der Eiszeit konnte man halt einfach hier, in der gemäßigten Zone,
sehr viel besser leben
und es hat sich dann halt auch die entsprechenden Umstände eingestellt,
hier das zu machen, mit der Landwirtschaft.
Ab wann kann man denn sagen...? – Schwierig.
Heute sagt man halt "die Jagd"
und dann macht sich einfach so einen Kulturfenster auf
und es gibt Dinge, die damit assoziiert sind und
alles andere ist irgendwie was anderes.
Bisher haben wir eigentlich immer das Ganze noch als Teil
des normalen Daseins angesehen.
Das war halt einfach Teil des Lebens.
Durch diese zunehmende Diversifizierung unserer Gesellschaft
und Spezialisierung, ist ja sozusagen auch diese Jagd,
mehr oder weniger, immer in einen etwas kleineren Bereich abgedreht worden
und hat sich dann sogar irgendwann zu einer Art Sport entwickelt
oder sagen wir mal einer Tätigkeit,
die vielleicht nicht unbedingt erforderlich immer war,
wenn man sich so den ganzen Adel anschaut oder ich weiß nicht.
Also Erfordernis also da kommen wir vielleicht später nochmal drauf.
Also zunächst mal war
Jagd und der Erfolg damit natürlich auch immer ein Stück weit etwas, mit
dem man sich brüsten konnte.
Also tut der Angler mit dem größten Fisch, der die Armspanne
überreicht und tut sicherlich auch der eine oder andere Jäger halt mit dem dicksten
Hirsch und in dem schwersten Kampf und
also die Geschichten, die man halt abends beim Bier erzählt.
Und was eben im Mittelalter passiert ist, ist dass die Jagd unter
Kontrolle des Adels gelangt ist.
Der die dann immer kulturell sicherlich
auch in neue Blüten getrieben hat,
also da hat sich auch eine Kunstszene drum entwickelt.
Da haben sich Fertigkeiten neu entwickelt.
Also Beizjagd mit dem
Vogel zu jagen zum Beispiel sind so Dinge, die zwar glaube ich irgendwie im
Arabischen oder Persischen ihren Ursprung haben, da bin ich aber jetzt auch
nicht ganz tief drin.
Also wenn ich mich so erinnere, es gibt halt viele Bildnisse von
irgendwelchen Fürsten und Herrschern mit einem Greifvogel auf der Hand,
wo die sich haben porträtieren lassen.
Das hat aber natürlich auf der anderen Seite
auch wirklich zu zu dekadenten Auswüchsen geführt.
Also die Spitzen fand ich
die sogenannten Einstelljagden, da hat man im Grunde in der Mitte eines
Reviers Bühnen aufgebaut und die Bevölkerung hatte das Wild halt dann in
der Mitte zusammen zu treiben und dann wurde halt da einfach schlichtweg
ein großer Haufen Wildtiere zusammen geknallt
Und dann haben die weiß gekelten Gesichter mit ihren Perücken halt:
"Huhuhu, da ist er aber wieder."
Also so in etwa stelle ich es mir vor.
Fast schon so Jahrmarkt.
Genau.
Und das Ganze ging aber auf der anderen Seite Hand in Hand also um
diese Belustigung
des Adels halt hinzukriegen, gabs halt dann ein zunehmendes Jagdverbot in
der Bevölkerung und da kommt übrigens auch diese Aufteilung von Hoch- und
Niederwild her, dass das Hochschild eben dem Adel vorbehalten war und das
Niederwild eben ab Reh abwärts da durfte sich der
Die Hasen dürft ihr euch noch holen, aber die Hirsche, die gehören uns.
Genau, so in der Richtung ging das.
Hatte aber eben auch andere Nachteile, also ich
meine die Bauernschaft in der Zeit war ja eher arm und wenn du deine
Existenz auf ein paar Quadratmeter Acker baust und die Horden Wildschweine
drehen um dann hast du schlichtweg ein Problem deine Familie zu kriegen
und das hat natürlich auch zu Spannungen geführt.
Also in Frankreich waren die
auch sehr extrem diese Spannungen, also das war ja auch in etwa zeitgleich,
dass die französische und die deutsche Revolution dann stattgefunden hat.
Man muss jetzt auch sehen, damals waren die Wälder im Eimer,
weil die einfach unglaublich ausgebeutet wurden zu Brennholzzwecken und die
langsam aufkommende Industrialisierung brauchte halt Energie.
Also wir reden jetzt so von Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts.
Genau, so vielleicht fünfzig hundert Jahre vorher also es ist ja immer eine
Entwicklung und die Forstbediensteten der Adelshäuser waren eigentlich schon
immer die, die so unterschwellig unter diesem Diktat des Adels geguckt
haben, dass sie die Wälder irgendwie in Ordnung kriegen und die hatten
natürlich auch in dem Zusammenhang ein Auge auf die Wildtiere also zumindest
soweit sie den Wald bewohnten.
Und dann ist die Revolution von 1848 hat halt
dazu geführt, dass das Jagdrecht mit dem Eigentum an Grund und Boden
verbunden wurde untrennbar.
Also mir gehört ein Stück Land und dann hab ich
auf diesem Land auch das Recht Jagd auszuüben.
Sie wurde dem Adel
weggenommen und wurde damit zu einem bürgerlichen Recht
und das waren ein Meilenstein
Der dann welche Auswirkungen hatte?
Erst mal gar nicht gute, weil nämlich wie entfesselt alles auf die alles...
Jeder losging.
Alles auf die Jacke gelegt wurde, was irgendwie nicht bei Drei auf den Bäumen war
Und deutsche Wildtiere können nicht so gut klettern.
Also ich habe
nebenher ein paar alte Schinken, also so alte Jagdliteratur aus Nachlässen,
die lasse ich mir schon mal gerne übereignen und es gibt zum Beispiel
"Diesels Niederjagd",
das ist so ein vor der,
also aus dem 19. Jahrhundert glaube ich, ist das Ding entstanden.
Da wird davon gesprochen, dass das Rehwild kurz vor der Ausrottung war.
Nun jetzt waren wir ja in einer Zeit, wo also so im Groben so Rousseau,
dieses zurück zur Natur also eine Naturverliebtheit, eine Romantisierung eintrat,
die insbesondere von den Forstbeamten auch ja quasi eingeatmet wurde und die
sich zu eigen gemacht haben.
Und man sah einfach die Notwendigkeit, wir
müssen an der Stelle was Regulatives tun.
Also einerseits in Sachen
fairer Umgang mit den Tieren, da formte sich der Begriff der
Weidgerechtigkeit und auf der anderen Seite ja so Themen wie Jagd und
Schonzeiten und wie kriegt man im Grunde die Natur wieder auf einen
leistungsfähigen Zustand zurück, die ja sehr stark ausgebeutet wurde also bevor die
Kohle ja entdeckt wurde.
Vorher hat man den Wald verheizt für die
Schwerindustrie, muss man sich ja auch mal klarmachen.
Ist vielleicht noch Randanekdote,
zum Beispiel hat man sehr viel Fichte im Bergbau verwendet.
Also Fichte hat den Vorteil, bevor sie bricht knackt knackt und knarzt sie ordentlich.
Buche bricht einfach durch und nun ist der Stollen dicht.
Also deshalb ist Fichte einfach für den Bergbau das Holz gewesen
Verstehe, weil es mehr Flexibilität hat sozusagen.
Genau und ein Warnmelder bevor es nachkippt.
Ja und die Jagdgesetze, also da gibt's ein
schönes Papier vom Wissenschaftlichen Dienst des Bundestages zu, die wurde von
Otto Braun im Grunde erdacht, das war so 1910/1920 rum
und war im Prinzip das erste Tier- und Naturschutzgesetz was es überhaupt gegeben hatte.
Also wenn natürlich auch noch...
Also jetzt überhaupt weltweit.
Ja, ich glaub sogar weltweit.
Ich bin jetzt nicht ganz sicher, aber für Deutschland kann ich es sicher sagen.
Und das ist halt in den ja irgendwie war es nicht durchgesetzt, also Otto Braun war,
wenn ich mich recht entsinne, der letzte preußische Ministerpräsident und
dieses Gedankengut schwillte aber durch und in Kraft gesetzt wurde dieses
Gesetz fast unverändert, nur mit einer anderen Präambel halt im Dritten
Reich, ich glaube 1936, unter Hermann Göring,
der damals irgendwie Reichsjagdmeister
war glaube ich der Titel war.
Und was man darin festgelegt hat,
ist halt unter anderem die Genetik des Reviersystems.
Also da kann man jetzt ja immer trefflich anderer Meinung drüber sein.
Also man kann sagen: "Ja das ist jetzt aus dem Dritten Reich
und deshalb ganz schlimm."
Andererseits kann man aber natürlich sagen, dass unter diesen Bedingungen
es möglich war ein solches Gesetz in Kraft zu rufen, ist auch irgendwie
eine ganz besondere Leistung.
Also das kann man jetzt so oder so sehen.
Also ich sehe es eher als eine besondere Leistung,
weil ich finde also weil darin nämlich
ja einfach eine grundsätzliche Haltung klar wird,
also ich habe wenig, wenn ich ablösen muss, aber
das Jagdrecht in seinem Paragraphen 1 vielleicht einfach nur mal
also Artikel 1: Das Jagdrecht ist die ausschließliche Befugnis auf einem
bestimmten Gebiet wildlebende Tiere, die dem Jagdrecht unterliegen zu
hegen, auf die Jagd auszuüben und sie sich anzueignen.
Mit dem Jagdrecht
ist die Pflicht zur Hege verbunden.
Also diese dieser Fürsorgegedanke steckt
einfach direkt im ersten Artikel mit drin.
Und das ist auch etwas, was
Jäger bis heute begleitet.
Also ich kann einfach nur abschöpfen,
einen Tierbestand dem es vorher gut gegangen ist.
Und das macht aus meiner Sicht
eigentlich sind ist die Jagd eigentlich die einzige Institution, wenn man
sie so nennen möchte, die flächendeckend als Anwalt und Fürsprecher der
Wildtiere von ihrer Anlage her eintritt.
Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts ging das ja auch
so mit den mit dem Umweltschutz eigentlich los.
Ist ja auch etwas, was man so vom Kopf her irgendwie gefühlt immer so mehr
in den Siebzigerjahren verortet,
so als Antwort auf diesen Überschwang.
Aber wenn man sich anschaut, so BUND
und ähnliche Organisationen haben ja im Prinzip
so ihre Quelle auch in dieser Zeit.
Das heißt, dieser Blick auf "der Mensch und seine Umwelt"
das ist ja etwas, was jetzt vielleicht nicht nur ausschließlich
in diesen Jagdkreisen entstanden ist
oder hängt das eng miteinander zusammen?
Wie muss man das sehen?
Also für mich sind es Geschwister.
Also ich als Jäger, ich verstehe mich als Naturschützer.
Ich möchte da draußen möglichst große
Vielfalt sehen und erhalten.
Und also ich weiß auch niemanden, der mehr Zeit da
draußen verbringt und dadurch hat man halt ein Interesse.
Also es ist ja, es ist ja ein Mitfühlen,
ein Einfühlen und also in die Zusammenhänge kommen was sicherlich auch gleich noch
ein bisschen tiefer rein, aber
es ist ein Interesse an den Tieren, weil wenn nicht mehr genug da sind,
tu ich mir selber als Jäger keinen Gefallen, weil dann kann ich nichts mehr
abschöpfen und sind es zu viele dann kommen auch Krankheiten rein und
andere Arten leiden darunter.
Es ist ja alles miteinander in Zusammenhang.
Ja vor allem, wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe,
durch diese Spezialisierung der Gesellschaft,
die im 20. Jahrhundert auch schon enorme Formen angenommen hatte,
gab's ja jetzt im Prinzip auch gar nicht so viele hauptberufliche Tätigkeiten,
die sich so unmittelbar eigentlich mit allem,
was nicht städtisch und nicht Landwirtschaft ist, auseinandergesetzt haben.
Außer dem, was die Jagd betrifft.
Oder übersehe ich da irgendetwas?
Also es ist im ländlichen Raum, also korrigiere mich, wenn ich jetzt auf die
falsche Fährte gerate, praktisch im Revierbetrieb ist es so, dass ein Landwirt
natürlich per Definition Interesse hat, auf seinem Stück Land eine Frucht
also eine Monokultur hinzukriegen.
Möglichst sortenrein und auch keine
Störung in seiner Ernte möchte und das auch in Ordnung.
Und wenn ich
Förster bin, also verfolge ich einen ähnlichen Zweck für Holz über längere
Zeiträume, weil die Umtriebszyklen einfach größere sind.
Und als Jäger bin ich eigentlich derjenige, der im Interessenausgleich mit den
anderen Nutzungsformen das Recht der Wildtiere einfordert.
Deren Lebensraum zu erhalten, die Hege eben.
Genau, die Hege.
Also ich geh halt her und sage: "Guck mal lieber Förster,
ich weiß du betreust einen Freizeitpark.
Ich weiß, du betreust ein Stück weit eine Holzplantage.
Aber du betreust auch einen Lebensraum."
Da kommt natürlich nicht nur mein
Reh und mein Damhirsche und mein Rothirsch und mein Fuchs und mein Hase drin vor.
Da kommen auch ganz viele andere Arten vor, aber wir müssen doch
irgendwie gucken, dass wir auf Augenhöhe unsere Interessen ausbalancieren
und gut nach Hause gehen können.
Inwiefern beschäftigt man sich denn mit diesem Jagdblick
auch mit allen Tieren,
die nicht unmittelbar bejagt werden?
Ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt jeder Vogel und jedes Kriechtier
automatisch Teil des Bejagens ist.
Also ich kann natürlich nicht für alle sprechen.
Ich gebe hier jetzt meine
Perspektive mit, aber ich bin zum Beispiel vor wenigen Wochen bin ich mal
zwei Tage mit einem Schädlingsbekämpfer mitgefahren und was der da macht
ist eigentlich Jagdausübung.
Also du musst dir mal klarmachen, jede Kakerlake,
die durch hoffentlich nicht deine Küche strauchelt oder jede
Silberfischchen ist ja nichts anderes als die Wildnis, die wieder anklopft
und zurückfordert.
Und wenn ich die gewähren lasse, dann schafft sie das.
Dann hält die Einzug.
Dann hält ihr Einzug und...
Letztendlich, also ich war in einer Bäckerei
in einer rheinischen Innenstadt.
In der Mitte eine Straßenbahnhaltestelle, vierspurige Straße, Bäckerei mit
Glasfront und dann bin ich mit dem mal mit dem Blick des Jägers und
Schädlingsbekämpfer da durch und dann hat er mir die Pässe gezeigt wo die
langen laufen, wo die hoch kriechen, wo die in die abgehängte Decke
reingehen, in welchen Faden die unter der Theke der Auslage herumgehen.
Und an diese Zwangspässe, also diese
Pässe wo die sich bewegen, stellt man halt Fallen auf
und will den hab, das ist Jagdausübung.
Wenn ich eine Maus fangen will, muss ich
lernen zu denken wie eine Maus.
Und das verbindet mich mit der Maus.
Und ich will die, ich will nicht, dass die leidet.
Aber ich muss ja auch meine
Kultur verteidigen.
Ich meine, ich esse die Maus auch hinterher nicht.
Die Kakerlake auch nicht.
Also früher hat man zum Schädlingsbekämpfer ja Kammerjäger gesagt.
Eigentlich ich finde es schönere Wort.
Stimmt. Das ist ja ein ganz passender Begriff.
Der Jäger in der Kammer.
Was wir ja jetzt im Prinzip verorten, so jetzt beim Geschichts-Durchmarsch,
wir kommen ja ein bisschen im Prinzip auch in unserer Zeit jetzt schon an,
auch wenn wir irgendwie noch hundert Jahre vorher irgendwie feststecken,
aber da hat sich ja im Prinzip dieses Kulturwesen,
wie wir es heute haben,
eigentlich auch manifestiert.
Das heißt, aus so einer revolutionär –
Also es gab, sagen wir mal so, diese Übergangsphase,
wo dieses Jagen einfach so einen tollen Status hatte,
dass die Reichen und Mächtigen und Schönen sich das sozusagen
schon richtig zum Sport haben gereichen lassen.
Mit dem Nachteil für die unterdrückten Massen,
die ja eigentlich von Landwirtschaft, zu dem Zeitpunkt,
noch nicht in dem Maße leben konnten,
weil es aber noch nicht die Mittel gab.
Also nicht die Techniken für eine effiziente Bewirtschaftung,
Schädlingsbekämpfung.
All das, sagen wir mal auch gerade ja die Technik
erst in den letzten 50 Jahren so richtig geschafft hat,
das alles zu überwinden.
Sodass quasi die Jagd eben noch wichtig war
und durch diese Revolution,
zumindest im Blick auf Deutschland,
hat sich das dann erst einmal quasi in so in wilde Zustände überführt,
weil jetzt konnte jeder auf einmal jagen
und man merkte, das schadet dem Ökosystem noch sehr viel mehr
und damit letztlich auch den Menschen.
Sodass man dann überhaupt erst auf den Punkt gekommen ist:
Okay, wir müssen das jetzt mal regulieren,
wir müssen es mal reglementieren.
Und der Blickwinkel ist:
Diese Lebewesen sind für uns auch wichtig
und sie einfach nur wegzukämpfen, bringt uns einfach nirgendwohin,
wo wir hin möchten
und deswegen müssen wir sozusagen einen Dualismus haben,
mit, ja, auf der einen Seite, ist es für uns Nahrungsquelle,
aber auf der anderen Seite müssen wir auch dafür sorgen,
dass deren Ökosystem und deren Leben in gewissen Bahnen geschützt wird,
damit das einfach eine Balance erfährt,
die für unsere Vorstellungen der Kulturlandschaft
und des Überlebens passt.
Jetzt habe ich schon wieder Balance gesagt.
Pfui.
Also eine Balance, sozusagen, für unsere Ziele.
Das ist es ja, sozusagen.
Also nicht der Natur, sondern eben ein Geben und Nehmen.
Spannend ist der Punkt des Ziels.
Das ist nämlich eigentlich alles, worum es sich dreht.
Also ich kann meine
Existenz ja nicht bestreiten, ohne mit meiner Umwelt und ihren Ressourcen
und ihren Lebewesen zu interagieren.
Und ich kann mir ein Ziel in den Kopf
setzen, was ich erreichen muss innerhalb dieser Interaktion.
Also eben drüber sinnieren, um vielleicht mal von einer ganz anderen Ecke zu
kommen, ist eine der ersten Fragen in solchen Gesprächen, die über diese
ganzen vielen Wertschöpfungsstufen hinweg so passieren also das sind ja auch
Distanzen eingetreten zwischen einer sehr städtischen Bevölkerung,
die überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, wie eine Handvoll Erde sich anfühlt und jemanden,
der da draußen wirklich sozialisiert ist.
Geh mal durch deine Lebensmittelvorräte und sag mir mal nur eine
Komponente, die du in deinem Stoffwechsel verarbeitest, die nicht entweder
gelebt hat oder Lebensraum für Tiere war, wenn ich die Trennung Pflanze
und Tier einführe.
Außer Salz, Salz lass ich gelten.
Ja, das Meiste wahrscheinlich.
Alles.
Also mir fällt keine Ausnahme ein.
Außer Salz.
Ja.
Also alles Mineralische.
Ja was ja aber auch irgendwo so in den Zyklen.
Also mein Sohn hat mich mal gefragt: "Wie kommt das Salz ins Meer?"
Da habe ich aber doof aus der Wäsche geguckt.
Und die Antwort, auf die ich dann später kam, ist Stein wird halt
ausgewaschen und wird über die Flüsse ins Meer transportiert, wo es sich konzentriert.
Deshalb sind die Meere sehr viel salzhaltige als Süßwasser-Geschichten.
Bildung für die Zukunft.
Dieses verstoffwechseln, also wenn ich jetzt mal weitergehe von unserem
persönlichen Stoffwechselkreislauf in überhaupt alles Leben, was auf diesem
Planeten passiert, dann ist es eigentlich so, dass das Leben dadurch
gekennzeichnet ist, dass Lebewesen sich gegenseitig verstoffwechselt in einer Tour.
Also sich gegenseitig fressen und Ausscheidungen gegen,
Ein- und Ausgabesystem zwischen
Ausscheidung und Nahrungsaufnahme hergestellt wird.
Also unsere Körper, die wir jetzt hier so vertraut sitzen, werden
irgendwann wieder Nahrung für irgendwelche Würmer Mikroorganismen sonst wie
sein und sich wieder in dieses zirkulierende System einfügen.
Und das bleibt auch nicht immer gleich, es verändert sich dauernd und das
ist die Störung also das, was im Negativen der Krebs ist, eine Mutation in
der Zelle, ist im Positiven ein Evolutionsschritt, der halt eine neue Art hervorbringt
Oder eine neue Fähigkeit.
Oder eine neue Fähigkeit oder irgendwie.
Also auf jeden Fall für diese
Dynamik nach vorne kämpft.
Also das so im Herzen zu sich genommen,
hat mir total die sich auf die Welt verändert.
Total anders.
Also vorher
bin ich immer so in Richtung der Perfektion, den letzten Bug aus dem
System kehren.
Alles muss toll sein.
Endlich fertig werden.
Ist Quatsch einfach
Quatsch.
Gibt’s nicht.
Gott sei Dank gibt's das nicht,
weil dann ist vorbei.
Weil, es muss sich einfach alles permanent ändern,
damit es sozusagen dieses Leben auch wirklich erfahren kann.
Und jetzt,  also vielleicht jetzt auf diesen Gedanken die die Populationsdynamik
mal draufgesetzt also so hat man mir vermittelt und ich finde es auch
relativ plausibel.
Also nehmen wir mal an, wir haben eine gegebenen
Nahrungsgrundlage und ich setze eine reproduktionsfähige Populationen
irgendeiner Tierart da drauf.
Dann nutzen die natürlich die
Nahrungsgrundlage und pflanzen sich fort und der Anstieg der Population
folgt so in etwa der steigenden Kurve einer Gaußschen Normalverteilung.
Also fängt flach an wird immer steiler, explodiert irgendwann förmlich und
geht dann irgendwann in die Sättigung hinein, um irgendwann Maximum dann
natürlich zu kriegen.
So und in dem Moment, wo es flacher wird und in die
Sättigung hineingeht, tauchen die ersten Individuen innerhalb der
Population auf, die nicht mehr genug Nahrung finden
Dann wird der Organismus schwächer, ein schwächerer Organismus ist
anfälliger für eine Krankheit und irgendeinen Erreger
Beziehungsweise für eine andere Lebensform,
die sozusagen diese Nahrungsquelle dann für sich urbar macht.
Ja genau und hab dann eben eine Dichte der Population, die es erlaubt, dass eine
Infektionsquelle sich bildet.
Also wo kriege ich leichter die Grippe beim
Waldspaziergang oder in einer S-Bahn in Berlin?
Ja ist klar, weißt was ich meine.
Und dann fängt natürlich einfach an also durch diese Übertragung des Erregers werden
dann irgendwann die anfälligsten Tiere raus sterben, die verdünnt sich
wieder die Population und irgendwann reißt die Infektionsquelle und dann
ist erst mal wieder gut
Das heißt, es pendelt sich auf so einem erträglichen Maß ein.
Da ist wieder die Idee des Gleichgewichts nochmal Quatsch.
Von da an
steigt es nämlich wieder an, bis der nächste Erreger kommt.
Also kriege im Grunde
jetzt nicht ganz genau wahrscheinlich, aber irgendwie so etwas wie eine
Sinus Kurve des An- und Absteigenden auf einem Niveau, was eben diese
Nahrungsgrundlage hergibt.
Gut, kann man ja auch problemlos beobachten.
Gerade so im Mittelalter mit den großen Seuchen,
die Pest et cetera oder auch mal so Cholera et cetera.
Andere, jetzt Ebola.
Also wenn immer mal wieder etwas versucht, dem Organismus Herr zu werden,
dem der Organismus so erst einmal nicht gewachsen ist,
dann kann es ja wirklich massive Einschränkungen haben.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie viele Leute
in den Pestzeiten umgekommen sind,
aber das waren schon signifikante Teile.
Große, große Prozentteile der Gesellschaft,
wo man sich dann halt auch schon fragen muss: Überleben wir das überhaupt?
Oder ist das jetzt sozusagen das Finale,
was uns für alle Ewigkeiten hinweg rafft?
Wobei es der Mensch ja dann immer geschafft hat,
sich durch seine Kulturtechniken
und das Lernen dann entsprechend auch zu wappnen und zu immunisieren,
durch Maßnahmen oder Erfindungen, um sich da wieder rauszuziehen.
Stimmt ist richtig, aber was wir ja also diese Kurve mit dem ansteigenden nur
mal vor Augen was wir ja nur geschafft haben, ist halt durch unsere
Kulturtechnik der Medizin einen Erreger nach dem anderen unschädlich zu machen.
Was eigentlich nur dafür sorgt, dass wir auf der gleichen
Nahrungsgrundlage immer mehr werden und auf der anderen Seite die
Nahrungsgrundlage immer weiter nutzen müssen
also immer intensiver auch nutzen müssen.
Das ist ja das, wo heute ja auch die ganzen Diskussionen sich so
drum brechen.
Die Effizienz der Landwirtschaft.
Ja genau.
Also jetzt kann man es also von da aus kann man jetzt in unterschiedliche
Richtungen weiterdenken.
Eine ist jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn ich also den Mensch eben unter dieser
Populationsdynamik sehe, kommt halt irgendwann der Erreger, gegen den ich
kein Mittel mehr haben und dann kann ich eigentlich nur naja entweder das
Recht zur Fortpflanzung einschränken oder das Lebensalter begrenzen.
Also ist jetzt ganz abstrakt und von oben betrachtet.
Wenn ich jetzt
andersherum an die Nahrungsgrundlage Landwirtschaft gehe, dann ist da im
Moment intensive Landwirtschaft zum Problem für den Artenschutz geworden
und das stimmt auch, gibt es viele Beispiele für, die andere Seite ist, gehe
ich denn wieder zurück auf eine weniger intensive Landwirtschaft, also das
was man vielleicht jetzt, ich nenne es mal öko oder Biolandbau, dann hab
ich auf der gleichen Fläche nur noch den halben Ertrag, heißt also ich
brauche die doppelte Fläche, habe also weniger Platz für naturnahe Räume
Oder noch anders: Ich produziere die Lebensmittel nicht mehr hier, wo es
toll und gut wächst, wir haben nahezu perfekte Bedingungen hier, dann gehts
vielleicht in Dritte-Welt-Ländern nach Afrika und da brauche ich gleich 20
fache Fläche für die gleiche Nahrungsmenge.
Mache wieder Lebensraum total in den letzten
Wildnisgebieten und so fängt es an ineinander zu wirken und man wird schier
wahnsinnig darüber
Weil es irgendwie so richtig keine Lösung gibt.
Ja, ist ein Heil für alle und Unendlichkeit also Unendlichkeit ist nicht die Lösung.
Heilung für alle ist nicht die Lösung.
Und dann also ist zumindest
meine Sicht der Dinge, der Tod ist wir brauchen den, wir brauchen ihn
genauso dringend wie die Geburt und die Zeugung.
Der ist wichtig, der macht
Platz für neues Leben.
Der Tod macht aus Lebewesen Lebensmittel
Und den muss man sogar mit einer gewissen Dankbarkeit entgegen nehmen.
Und ich sagt ja auch aus einer persönlichen Betroffenheit heraus, weil mein
eigener Vater ist nämlich über fünf Monate unter voll Beatmung dahin geschieden.
Das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt, ich war nicht zu jedem Zeitpunkt sicher, ob
der das wirklich so wollte.
Okay, kommen wir doch vielleicht noch so ein bisschen auf
die konkrete Jagdwelt, wie sie sich jetzt im Besonderen
in Deutschland so abspielt.
Jetzt haben wir ja gelernt:
Jagdgesetze wurden eingeführt
und haben sozusagen Rechte und Pflichten damit auch eingeführt.
Das ist irgendwie schon einmal relativ klar,
unter welchen Bedingungen das stattfinden kann.
Was ist denn sozusagen das Ergebnis
und wie stellt sich denn das heutzutage dar, also wenn man Jäger ist
oder wer auch sonst noch an diesem System sage ich mal teilnimmt,
welche Präsenz hat das sozusagen in unserer Gesellschaft?
Man sieht das ja nun selten genug.
Gerade wenn man so ein Stadt-Ei ist wie ich,
hat man da wirklich fast gar keine Berührung damit.
Kann wirklich tatsächlich auch nur sehr wenig Erfahrungen
und Momente in meinem Leben aufbringen,
wo mir das auch überhaupt nur mal über den Weg gelaufen ist.
Ich weiß noch, ich bin irgendwann mal durch Schottland gewandert,
kam über irgend so einen Hügel, da stand dann ein kleiner LKW
mit einer Verladerampe und ich schaute da so drauf
und dann lag dann halt so ein Hirsch.
Mehr oder weniger frisch geschossen vermutlich.
Und ich so: „Oh!“
Ist ja jetzt nicht so, ja Teestuben und so, Whisky-Brauereien gab's ja in größerer Zahl so.
Auf einmal war so das und da dachte ich mir so:
"Oh! Ok, hier findet irgendwie auch noch so ein bisschen Natur statt.
Jenseits der ausgetretenen Touristenpfade."
Wie ist dieses Jagdsystem bei uns integriert?
Wie findet das statt? Was war der Begriff?
Revier...
Reviersystem.
Revier-System? Was was ist dieses Revier-System?
Also wir haben ja seit 1848 eben die Bindung des Jagdrechts an Grund und Boden
und das ist praktisch betrachtet so, dass wir
zwei Welten haben und das sind die sogenannten Eigenjagden und die
gemeinschaftlichen Jagden oder was die Reviere angeht.
Eine Eigenjagd
habe ich ab 75 Hektar.
Dann kann ich auf meinem eigenen Grund und Boden
eben die Jagd ausüben, das Jagdrecht ausüben.
45 Hektar.
70, 75.
75 Hektar. Hektar war irgendwie...
hundert mal hundert.
Hundert mal Hundert, okay.
Und die gemeinschaftlichen Jagdbezirke da wird zusammengefasst alle
Flächen, die kleiner sind.
Und dann gibt es die sogenannten befriedeten Bezirke.
Das ist Stadt, Friedhof, Privatgrundstück.
Und jetzt steht man vor der Wahl übe ich also im gemeinschaftlichen ist es so,
dass das Jagdrecht dann verpachtet wird an jemanden, der sich interessiert
und der...
Also kann, aber nicht muss.
Ja, gemeinschaftlich muss man eigentlich, weil man ja die ja
die Genossen dieser Jagdgenossenschaft, die müssen ja, die bündeln ihre
Interessen ja innerhalb der Genossenschaft.
Also die Idee ist schon so,
dass die gemeinschaftlich ihre Interessen da vertreten.
Jetzt kann es zwar sein,
dass einer der Jagdgenossen gleichzeitig in Tateinheit auch Pächter,
Jagdpächter ist, aber es muss eben nicht so sein.
Und ja als Eigenjagdbesitzer
stehe ich halt vor der Frage, mache ich selber oder verpachte ich?
Auch ganz oder teilweise also ich kann auch sagen, ja ich verpachte mein Jagdrecht,
aber das Rehwild will ich alleine bejagen oder ich hätte gerne...
Das darf man dann auch?
Das darf man.
also dort herrscht im Prinzip Vertragsfreiheit erstmal
Da muss man auch keine Ausbildung haben?
Keine besonderen weiteren persönlichen Erlaubnisse, um das zu tun?
Jetzt ausbildungsmäßig, okay.
Welche weiteren Hürden mich sozusagen noch davon abhalten können,
da tatsächlich mal mit der Flinte in den Wald zu ziehen.
Hey, wir sind in Deutschland.
Jetzt hast du das Fass aufgemacht, jetzt gucken wir auch rein.
Irgendwas gibt's da bestimmt.
Also man kann ab einem Alter von 18 eine Jägerprüfung ablegen
und es gibt noch einen Jugendjagdschein,
den man, da kann man die Prüfung ablegen, aber dann praktisch die Jagdausübung
nur in Begleitung eines älteren Jägers über 18.
Ich glaub mindestens über 18, aber
Unsicherheiten sind ja erlaubt.
So und der Kurs ist nach Landesgesetz vorgeschrieben.
Eine Prüfung in dem einen Bundesland hat aber Gültigkeit
in den anderen Bundesländern.
Umfasst so wie ich ihn gemacht habe 120 Unterrichtsstunden.
Also drei Wochen Vollzeit im Prinzip wenn man so will
bei einer 40-Stunden-Woche plus praktische Geschichten, wie Hochsitzbau,
Reviergänge, Pflanzenbestimmung, diese Dinge.
Also umfasst fünf Fächer.
Kriege ich sie alle zusammen?
Also Waffenrecht und Waffenkunde, Wildbrethygiene,
Wildbiologie, Hundewesen und Brauchtum und Naturschutzgeschichten glaube ich auch.
Das sind ja schon fast mehr als fünf, oder?
Ja dann streichen wir das raus.
Waffenwesen, Wildbrethygiene, Hundewesen, Brauchtum.
Ja Hundewesen und Brauchtum ist ein Fach.
Ja dann legt man eine schriftliche und eine mündliche Prüfung ab.
Eine Prüfungskommission setzt sich wieder zusammen aus Vertreter der unteren
Jagdbehörde, des Naturschutzes und hab ich vergessen.
Also das ist jetzt bei mir
auch schon ein bisschen her, aber drei bis fünf Peoples sind da zusammen
und wenn das wissen entsprechend nachgewiesen ist,
dann hat man eine bestandene Jägerprüfung.
Dann schließt man eine Jagd-Haftpflichtversicherung ab,
geht damit zur unteren Jagdbehörde, die jeder Kreis- oder Stadt halt hat und sagt:
"Ich hätte jetzt gerne einen Jagdschein gelöst."
Und die gibt's glaub ich von der
Dauer von einer Woche bis zu drei Jahren in Nordrhein-Westfalen zumindest
ist es so.
Also ich löse immer gleich den Dreijährigen, der es halt
in Summe Rabatt gibt's, auf einen längeren gibt es Rabatt.
Mit der Prüfung hat man kann den im Prinzip beliebig lang machen.
Und mit dem lösen des Jagdscheins hab ich dann auch gleichzeitig
zweites Rechtsgebiet, die Berechtigung eine Waffe zu kaufen.
Aber Umgang mit der Waffe war ja auch Teil dieser Ausbildung.
Man lernt auch schießen.
Ist aber nur so, habe, löse ich keinen Jagdschein, habe ich keine Berechtigung
meine Waffe zu besitzen.
Weil ich keinen Bedarf nachweisen kann.
Das heißt, zu diesem Jagdschein lässt man es eigentlich erst kommen,
wenn man auch wirklich vorhat, es auszuüben.
Ich sag mal es gibt natürlich auch Welche,
die sagen, ja jetzt habe ich die Waffen, ich meine
die kosten ja auch teilweise viel Geld und um die zu behalten, löse ich mir halt
regelmäßig den Jagdschein weiter.
Also ist ja Leben geht ja praktisch auch immer hoch
und runter und wie das dann so ist.
Wenn ich jetzt nach Ablauf der Gültigkeitszeit neu haben will,
muss ich dann nochmal eine Prüfung ablegen oder reicht einmal für immer?
Oder muss man dann irgendwas auffrischen oder so?
Nee nee, einmal reicht für immer, aber ich muss halt immer wieder
persönlich zur Behörde gehen und dahinter steckt dann im Grunde eine
vollständige Offenbarung und Durchleuchtung, weißt ja Terrorismus und so
Ja.
Naja gut, aber ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt, was weiß ich,
wenn man in der Zwischenzeit nochmal fünf Banken überfallen hat und so,
dann überlegen die sich das vielleicht noch mal den Jagdschein.
Ja ja, deshalb auch das persönliche Auftreten.
Die holen dann auch irgendwie ein
Führungszeugnis und polizeilich und diese ganzen Dinge,
dann käme man da nicht weiter.
Ist jetzt durchaus eine sinnvolle Struktur.
Findest du das schon übertrieben?
Sagen wir mal so...
Jäger beklagen sich da ja.
Habe ich gehört.
Ja, das gehört ja auch zum guten Ton, sonst gehört man ja nicht wirklich dazu.
Also ich sage mal ja, es ist in gewisser Hinsicht gut, also ganz so liberal wie es
woanders ist, man geht einfach in den Laden und kauft sich, was man gerne hätte,
halte ich für nicht richtig und ich sage mal wenigstens der
persönliche Anschein den halte ich auch für wichtig, weil wir sind nämlich
die einzige private Personengruppe, die mit scharfen Schusswaffen die auch
Tötungsabsicht haben, also hat noch was mit Munition zu tun, kommen wir vielleicht
noch mal drauf, die da frei draußen rumlaufen.
Also rechtlich unterscheidet man
das Transportieren einer Waffe und das Führen einer Waffe.
Und führen also im Sinne
scharfe Schusswaffe mit inklusive Munition geladen in der Waffe,
gibt's außer den Jägern und den Polizei,
ich glaub Militär darf es noch ein bisschen, nur ganz
wenige private Sicherheitsleute, die im Personenschutz
nach dreifacher chemischen Reinigung und so.
Also das ist eine echte Verantwortung, die man dann natürlich auch hat.
Die andere Seite der gleichen Medaille ist aber,
man ist auch extrem angreifbar.
Durch wen?
Durch jeden
Inwiefern?
Sag halt einfach, der hat aber...
Achso, angreifbar im Sinne von...
die Waffe auf mich gerichtet und dann
hat man einen regen Schriftwechsel.
Also das geht auch ganz schnell also man ist ja eben dadurch,
dass man eigentlich diese immense Gewalt der Waffe
unter seiner Verantwortung hat, ist man total verletzlich.
Hätte ich jetzt vielleicht gar nicht so öffentlich sagen sollen,
aber ich finde die Bevölkerung da draußen hat auch eine Verantwortung mit ihren
Anzeigen ein bisschen sorgsamer umzugehen.
Ist das wirklich ein richtiges Problem?
Bisweilen.
Also man hat
schon mit einem SEK eine kleine Jagdgesellschaft auf Taubenjagd
auf den Bauch gelegt und terroristisch verarbeitet.
Weil irgendjemand gesagt hat: „Da laufen Leute mit Waffen durch den Wald.“
Ja man ist halt getarnt also vermummt im Terrorismus-Deutsch und dann wird
man gibt's halt Leute, die sind ja hinreichend sensibilisiert worden auf
vermummte Gestalten und dann geht die Welt unter und...
Verstehe, die Paranoia greift da sozusagen auch etwas um sich.
Na klar.
Also es gibt glaube ich in Deutschland jeden Tag zwei Tote durch Gewaltverbrechen
und wenn du das Fernsehen anmachst hab ich mal, hat einer gezählt 427.
Pro Tag.
Im Fernsehen ja.
Und entsprechend die Leute gucken halt nur Fernsehen, als sich mit der
Realität zu beschäftigen und dann kommt das halt so.
Lattenzaun Tatort.
Genau.
Ja also da also das ist jetzt auch nicht dauernd, aber
der Umgang mit Bevölkerung aus dieser
Perspektive als Waffenträger erfordert auch ein gutes Fingerspitzengefühl.
Und jeder Mensch ist anders.
Ja ok, verstehe ich.
Aber kommen wir nochmal so zur konkreten Jagdausübungen zurück.
Also, ich muss mich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen.
Ich muss eine Prüfung machen und lerne dabei über verschiedenste Aspekte,
vom Waffengebrauch, allgemeinen Regeln, aber halt auch sozusagen
Naturverständnis, Pflanzenbestimmung, Hundewesen
und weiß nicht, was noch alles mit reinfällt.
Wildbiologe, ja also so Sozialverhalten, Altersstrukturen, verträgliche Wilddichten
Also man lernt eigentlich schon relativ viel,
was man normalerweise nicht lernen würde.
Man kriegt wahrscheinlich auch einen Blick für die Natur,
den man so wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht gehabt hat. Oder?
Ich sehe auf einmal überall Rehe, überall sind sie.
Also du denkst, dass überall welche sind? Oder, du siehst sie auf einmal?
Nein nein die sind wirklich da.
Wenn ich denken würde, wären sie weiß ich aber
Also wenn ich jetzt mit einem Auto auf einer Landstraße, auf einer Autobahn,
auf einmal sehe ich sie überall stehen, habe ich früher nie wahrgenommen.
Wie war das so für dich, als du diese Prüfungen gemacht hast?
Was ist da so mit dir passiert?
Ja die Prüfung war, also ich mein gut, das ist halt eine bestandene Prüfung man freut
sich natürlich einfach mal so und...
Ja, ich mein überhaupt durch diesen ganzen Lern...
Durch diese Lernphase auch durchzugehen,
die Erfahrungsphase damit verbunden.
Ja ich will jetzt nicht so total verklärt werden, aber ich sage mal es ist eine
also eigentlich ist es eine Prüfung, mit der man die Qualifikation erlernt,
mit dem Lernen überhaupt erst anzufangen.
Also es ist eins der ganz wenigen
Handwerke, wenn nicht das einzige, was man erst ausüben darf,
nachdem man die Prüfung bestanden hat
Ich darf ja vorher nicht zur Jagd gehen ohne bestandene Jägerprüfung.
Aber Ärzte...
Ja unter Aufsicht oder so schnibbeln die vielleicht,
ich weiß noch nicht genau weiß ich jetzt da nicht so gut.
Also ich weiß nur, ich kriege es auseinander, aber nie wieder
zusammen, wenn ich so ein Tier hab.
So viel zu meinen medizinischen Kenntnissen
Ja gut, aber unabhängig davon.
Was hast du da erlernt, womit du vielleicht nicht gerechnet hast,
dass du damit konfrontiert werden würdest?
Für mich bedeutsam ist, ich bin völlig eigenständig, mit meinen
Möglichkeiten in der Lage, mir aus Natur Ernährung zu bauen.
Das war ich vorher nicht.
Okay, also Tier-Ernährung.
Beeren sammeln hättest du ja jetzt wahrscheinlich schon vorher können.
Hätte ich vorher auch können, aber auch darüber weiß ich eine Ecke mehr.
Da kommen Sachen dazu, die also zum Beispiel so was wie eine Eiruhe.
Also Rehwild hat seine
Fortpflanzungszeit Ende Juli, Anfang August die Blattzeit wie wir Jäger sagen und
das befruchtete Ei wird quasi eingelagert und zwar bis zur
Wintersonnenwende und erst dann beginnt der Embryo zu reifen.
Das macht der Dachs und das Reh.
Und das ist eine Fähigkeit, da wusste ich vorher gar nichts von.
Ich meine die ganze Natur ist so Frühling es fort, es ist Setzzeit.
Brut- und Setzzeit wie wir sagen.
Da hat die Natur ihre Kinderstube.
Das ist dann sozusagen so getimed,
dass die Tragzeit dann quasi durch den Winter geht
und dann sozusagen im Frühling die Kinder kommen.
Dass das alles so getimed ist, egal wann es jetzt zum Akt kam.
Ja wenn die Temperaturen wieder stimmen,
wenn die Vegetation halt explodiert, dass dann
einfach die optimale Zeit ist, sein Nachwuchs auch durchzubringen so
organisiert sich die Natur.
Stell dir mal vor, dass wär beim Menschen so.
Das wäre eine Kindergeburtstagsphase. Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Ja du, guck dir den Kölner Karneval an.
Also Strukturen entdecken, die wie tickt dieser Computer, dieses System da
draußen, wie greife ich ein also was war vorhin kurz hatten so dieses wie viele Tiere
auf welcher Nahrungsgrundlage.
Ist, also jetzt nun mal um ein Beispiel Rotwild
ist zum Beispiel eine Art, die aus Sicht des Forstes sehr unerwünscht ist,
also die es eigentlich ein Steppen-Bewohner also Schottland oben, weite Hügel, wo die
weit gucken können.
Das sind so Lebensräume, die das Rotwild gerne hat, um
sich halt einfach, um Fressfeinde relativ früh zu erkennen.
Früh erkennen zu können, ja.
Gleichzeitig ist Rotwild aber auch ein Kulturflüchter.
Jetzt haben wir eine sehr eng
besiedelte Landschaft und das drängt das Rotwild in die Wälder zurück.
Jetzt haben die halt natürlich auch nicht so wahnsinnig toll viel zu
fressen als Wiederkäuer mit Pansen und ihrem Verdauungssystem,
dann fangen die an halt die Bäume zu schälen,
die Rinde runter zu knabbern, da geht dann
eine Fäule rein der Baum stirbt ab.
??? (Reve) fressen die Naturverjüngung auch ab.
Das ist im Moment so ein Thema, das ist so ein klassischer Waldwild-Konflikt.
Der tobt heftig.
Eine der ganz heiß diskutierten Themen.
So und jetzt kann ich
aus also ich sage mal die Extremen, also der Forst will, dass sein Wald
prosperiert und die Naturverjüngung heißt ja nichts anderes, als dass der
Samen, den die Bäume abwerfen in ihrer Mast, so nennt man das, sie sich
in Triebe hoch bringt.
So Wild findet frische Pflanzen echt lecker.
Und der Förster sagt:"Naja, dann ist doch auch doof, weil da muss ich erstens Setzlinge kaufen
und mühsam Pflanzen und diese Setzlinge auch noch Eingattern, damit das
Wild nicht reinkommt und das macht alles Kosten und die Vielfalt und
Naturverjüngung und weg mit dem Wild."
So extrem, ich will dem jetzt auch nicht
Unrecht tun, weil da gibt es auch echt gute drunter.
Na gut, aber ist halt auf jeden Fall ein Interessenskonflikt.
Ja genau.
Und jetzt kann ich
natürlich hergehen und da gibt's auch ganz extreme Dinge,
also im Moment tobt ein Krieg im Erzgebirge.
Da ist eine Forstbewirtschaftung im Moment unterwegs, die sieht Jagd
einfach als Dienstleistung des Waldbaus
und da ist eine Vorgehensweise, dass die den Rotwildbestand mit zwei Drückjagden,
müssen wir auch noch drauf kommen, pro Woche von Oktober bis
Januar halt soweit reduzieren,
dass die Setzlinge von alleine sicher hochkommen.
So und dann steht man als Jäger der
natürlich tötet.
Ja stimmt.
Steht man da auf der anderen Seite als
Lobbyist des Wildtieres
Aber sozusagen im Auftrag des Holz, der Holzwirtschaft.
Ja.
Da eiert es wieder durch.
Also ich sage mal grundsätzlich halte ich es schon für richtig, dass der
Grundeigentümer die Interessen und die Zielsetzung vorgibt.
Also ich kann
einen Wald mit wirtschaftlichen Ziel betreiben, ich kann einfach einen
schönen Wald wollen, ich kann den als Lebensraum bewirtschaften, ich kann
den als Freizeitpark bewirtschaften.
Und all diese Nutzungsinteressen
zwischen diesen Polen, zwischen Holzplantage, Freizeitpark und Lebensraum,
die sind natürlich irgendwie drin und diese Gleichgewichte damit zu
finden, das ist halt eine Herausforderung, vor der man da ständig steht.
So und ich kann jetzt natürlich
also dem extremen Forstmann, der das Wild nach Möglichkeit weg haben will,
dem kann ich dienlich sein, aber dann frage ich mich als Jäger
natürlich auch irgendwie:
"Ey, ich will, ich will hier auch gesunde Wildtiere haben."
Also siehe Jagdgesetz, einen gesunden der Nahrungsgrundlage und den
Landeskulturellen Verhältnissen angepassten Wildbestand.
Also muss ich da auch
Kontra geben.
Habe auf der anderen Seite wieder so kleine Tücken, die mir
entgegenschlagen mögen aus den anderen Dingen und sagt vielleicht auch, wir
können doch auch anders rangehen.
Also zum Beispiel weiß man beim Rotwild,
dass Fütterung halt was bedeutet.
Also Fütterung in Notzeiten halte ich für eine
Verpflichtung, wenn ich denen die Wanderwege zu ihren Nahrungsquellen
abschneide, die gehen nämlich über keine vierspurige Straße mehr drüber
als Kulturflüchter.
Ich weiß aber auch, wenn die schlecht ernährt werden, dann
setzen die weniger Hirsche in die Welt, dann setzen die mehr weibliches
Wild in die Welt, das heißt da die vorhandenen Hirsche können mehr weibliches
Wild beschlagen und dann hab ich unterm Strich halt meinen mein Schäl- und
Verbissproblem potenziert.
Also ist neben dem Abschuss eine gezielte und gekonnte
Fütterung und auch noch mit den richtigen Mitteln durchaus eine Maßnahme,
die halt bei der Steuerung solcher Populationen im Einklang mit den ganzen
Interessen, ein Faktor ist.
Okay, das heißt die Jagd besteht eigentlich gar nicht mal nur
aus dem Aufspüren und Töten,
sondern ist sozusagen auch noch etwas vielschichtigere
Dialog mit der Lebewesenstruktur.
Ein Berufsjäger hat mir mal gesagt, wir gestalten einen Lebensraum, weil wir
einfach wissen, also am besten von allen Beteiligten wissen, wie die
Zusammenhänge sind.
Also ganz eindringliches Beispiel an der Stelle ist,
jetzt lachst du dich kaputt, ein Flughafen.
Wieso?
Bei Vogelschlag ist zum Beispiel eine echte Bedrohung für den Flugverkehr
und jeder Verkehrsflughafen, der etwas auf sich hält, hat mindestens einen
Berufsjäger am Start
Der dann im Wesentlichen was tut?
Der die Lebensraumverhältnisse für Wildarten, die dem Flugverkehr
gefährlich werden können so verschlechtert, dass die da Möglichkeit keine
Zwischenfälle mehr passieren.
Also heißt konkret Ansitzeinrichtungen für
Bussarde rausnehmen zum Beispiel.
Bepflanzungen, Zäune, gucken dass die nicht geeignet sind.
Heißt die Mahd auf
den Wiesenflächen so anzulegen, dass ungefähr kniehoch stehen bleibt, damit
ein Bussard von einer Ansitzeinrichtung ein Kaninchen oder eine Maus gar
nicht mehr sehen kann.
Und sich damit dann die Bussarde woanders hin trollen.
Sind im Wesentlichen diese Greifvögel das Problem?
Auch Rabenvögel sind ein Problem.
Also da musst du zum Beispiel gucken, dass das Aas
schnell wieder weg ist.
Gleichzeitig aber übrigens auch also gerade in Köln, wo
ich einen Freund von mir genau diese Funktion wahrnimmt, das ist eines der
bedeutendsten Naturschutzgebiete der Republik die Wahner Heide, da sind
selten Orchideen und Pflanzen und die kommen ja auch auf dem
Flughafengelände vor.
Und auch das ist eine Kooperation, die zwischen
Jagd und Naturschutz dann an der Stelle stattfindet.
Verstehe. Also hat sozusagen jeder Kulturraum
auch seine eigenen Anforderungen,
seine eigenen Ziele.
Und letzten Endes, ist es dann, unter anderem,
aber eben auch an Jägern,
für den jeweiligen Kulturraum, die richtigen Maßnahmen zu ergreifen,
um die eigentlichen Ziele, sei es mehr Naturschutz,
mehr Artenschutz, oder eben Lebensraumgestaltung, um die dann zu erfüllen.
Also ein ständiges aufmerksames Wahrnehmen, was passiert hier, ein dauernder
Dialog mit allen, die daran beteiligt sind, unter allen möglichen Aspekten,
also von finanziellen Geschichten über Artenschutz bis wann kommt wo welche
Mahd oder welcher Mähdrescher zustande, wie gehen die damit um über den
Dialog mit Freizeitnutzern, die überhaupt keine Idee haben.
Also das kann auch ich Hundebesitzer, also ich habe mal irgendwie zwei kleine Münsterländer, die Karnickel
jagten und die dazugehörige Frau: "War doch nur Spaß."
Kaninchen kann halt
nicht zum Tierarzt gehen.
Das ist auch praktischer Tierschutz, die
Wildtiere davor zu beschützen.
Okay, wenn ich jetzt so ein bisschen drüber nachdenke,
wird mir irgendwie auch so ein bisschen klar,
dass vor allem so dieses Bild, was man glaube ich hat,
so der Jäger, der sitzt in seiner Jagdhütte
und dann ab und zu ist mal Zeit, mal wieder ein paar Tiere abzuknallen.
Dann geht man halt mal raus und dann ist man wieder drin.
So kann das gar nicht funktionieren.
Sondern man kann eigentlich diesen Auftrag,
den jeweiligen, den man dort zu verfolgen hat
und den man erfüllt sehen möchte, der kann eigentlich auch nur stattfinden,
wenn man eben eigentlich die ganze Zeit Teil dieses Systems ist,
indem man vor allem auch viel beobachtet.
Man muss ja auch quasi die Ergebnisse in irgendeiner Form bewerten.
Hat meine Maßnahme jetzt auch zu dem gewünschten Ziel geführt?
Oder hat sie vielleicht irgendeinen Seiteneffekt gehabt,
den ich so noch gar nicht auf den Zeiger hatte.
Das heißt, man ist eigentlich noch zum Großteil vor allem unterwegs.
Also so ein vollberuflicher Jäger beobachtet im Wesentlichen die ganze Zeit
und denkt darüber nach, was da eigentlich getan werden muss.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein bisschen so eine Tätigkeit wie Programmieren.
Ja, ich sage ja ältester Hacker-Sport der Welt.
Es muss ja auch erst mal so ein bisschen bewusst werden.
Also ich meine wie jede also Jagd ist ein Handwerk
und wie jedes Handwerk kann man Jagd gut
und schlecht ausüben.
Was aber natürlich unfair ist, ist die schlechten
Beispiele für alle stellvertretend hinzustellen, sondern fair wäre doch mal
hinzugucken und erst mal zu verstehen wie Zusammenhänge sind, weil Fehler
immer passieren also fehlerfreie Software gibt's ja auch nicht.
Nee gibt’s nicht, leider. Nicht wirklich. Nur so im beschränktem Maße.
Na dann lass vielleicht noch mal kurz bisschen was zu dieser Wahrnehmung
durch die Gesellschaft sagen.
Also, ich hab da immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck,
die Jagd hat so ein bisschen schlechten Stand.
Es irgendwie so ein etwas missverstandener Bereich,
oder vielleicht auch etwas, was einfach vielen Leuten so fern ist,
dass da einfach die Grundlagen des Verständnisses fehlen.
Ich merke das ja auch grade selber an mir,
dass bestimmte Aspekte hier einfach aufkommen.
Dass man sich so denkt: „Hm ja, so hab ich das noch gar nicht gesehen.“
Wie ist denn so dieser Dialog mit der Gesellschaft?
Also jetzt muss ich eigentlich so in mehrere Richtungen mal gehen.
Wir haben,
also um vielleicht einmal den Blick nach innen in die Jägerschaft zu sehen,
ich weiß ja aus meiner eigenen Geschichte,
dass ich über dieses virtuelle extrem
arbeitsteilige Leben irgendwann mit Mitte 30/40 also so ein typisches Alter bei
vielen auf einmal so einen Hunger nach draußen verspürte
Wenn ich jetzt an irgendeiner Spielekonsole sozialisiert bin und spiel da
mein Ego-Shooter und werde erschossen,
dann habe ich noch sieben Leben.
Und ich glaube Christian Grasse hatte das in
seinem Vortrag und wenn ich das Virtuelle realer machen möchte
und ich fange dann an zu bluten, dann sage ich:
"Boa ist das aber gut gemacht hier."
Also das klingelte in meiner, weil wenn ich als Jäger etwas tue, dann hat das
unmittelbare und existenzielle Konsequenzen, die ich auch sofort verspüre.
In allen möglichen Dimensionen.
So und jetzt kommt jemand, der ich sage mal
über diesen Weg von Wohnungen in Tiefgarage klimatisierten Auto und wieder
ins Büro und seinen Besprechungen irgendwie sozialisiert wird mit diesem
Hunger und dieser virtualisierten Prägung nach da draußen,
also macht eine Prüfung, wo auch nur: "Arbeiten wir das so ab."
Also das gibt's ja durchaus.
Und kommt dann halt über eine Einnahmequelle von
weiß ich nicht 100 paar und Euro auf eine Drückjagd,
also man muss diese Stände, die man da hat, bezahlen,
also das sind so Gesellschaftsjagden auf Schalenwild.
Dann jagt der, als wenn der ein Computerspiel machen würde.
Und Technik auf den Waffen
führt auch dazu, dass das Leben halt fünfzig/hundert Meter entfernt
ausgehaucht wird und mich gar nicht mehr so unmittelbar erreicht.
Und ich weiß noch, ich habe meine erste Sau
auf 5 Meter erlegt und ich habe halt klappern hören,
wie die letzten zwei Versuche die Lunge noch einmal zu füllen
weggehen und förmlich spürbar, wie das Leben diesen Körper verlässt und das ist,
das ist eine riesengroße Verantwortung, die einfach über die
Virtualisierung, die wir in allen Lebensbereichen verspüren, verlorengeht
und über die immer besser werdende Technik, die auch im Umfeld der Jagd und
der Waffen eben zur Verfügung stellt halt einfach verloren geht.
Also das ist etwas,
da suche ich auch, das ist mir auch immer so ein Anliegen, das so nach innen in
die Herzen zu bringen.
Oder der Kampf gegen die Wildschäden ist auch ein
wirtschaftliches Thema, weil wir sind ja nicht mehr so sehr aus unserer
Verantwortung für unsere Umwelt heraus lebend, sondern für uns zählt nur noch
Erfolg und Sieg oder Niederlage,
monetäre Dinge also Umsatzziele im Vertrieb habe ich ja auch selber lange
genug erlebt und darunter gelitten.
Sehr abstrakt.
Und jetzt habe ich das Schlimmste an
Wildschaden, was ich mal gehört habe, war pro Jahr 75 000 Euro, nur weil
Wildschweine durch einen Acker pflügen und nach Eiweiß suchen.
So und jetzt hast du System-Dinge.
Also du hast zum Beispiel einen Rübenacker und jetzt kommt der Bauer hat vorne dran ein Grubber,
also wo die Oberfläche umgedreht wird
und die Restfrüchte der Rüben liegen da noch rum,
weil sie nicht vollständig abgeerntet wurden und hintendran einen dicken
Pflug und pflügt die einen halben Meter oder ein Meter unter die Erde.
Dann hast du halt perfekte Bedingungen für allerlei Engerlinge und Getier, Eiweiß,
wo die Sauen wieder ins Feld wechseln und im nächsten Jahr hüfttiefe Löcher buddeln,
wo dir der Bauer hinterher wieder gegenüber steht und sagt:
"Hand auf, Wildschäden, jetzt."
Und das sind Zusammenhänge, die muss ich begreifen.
Und ich muss im richtigen Moment das Feld unter meiner Beobachtung haben
und auch die Gespräche suchen.
Also der Bauer fordert vom Jäger Wildschaden ein.
Wildschaden, ja.
Das steht in aller Regel in den Pachtverträgen,
dass der Jagdpächter wildschadenersatzpflichtig.
Das können die Karnickel sein, die in die frische Saat vom Weizen gehen,
das sind eben meistenteils Wildschweine, das ist aber auch Rehwild oder Rotwild,
was halt im Wald
die Naturverjüngung oder die frisch gepflanzte Sturmfläche halt gerade begeistert.
Das ist so eine Konstellation,
wo der Bauer vielleicht der Eigentümer ist,
dieser gesamten Ländlichkeiten.
Ein großer Teil davon wird als landwirtschaftliche Nutzfläche
zum Einsatz gebracht.
Und was darüber hinaus noch an Fläche ist,
wird mit Pachtvertrag an Jäger abgegeben
und in dem Vertrag steht drin:
Ziel dieses Lebensraums, ist die Koexistenz mit der Landwirtschaft.
Kriegt das mal hin!
Und wenn du jetzt die Sauen nicht unter Kontrolle kriegst,
dann hast du mir einen Verdienstausfall zu kompensieren.
Weil sonst hast du deinen Vertrag nicht erfüllt.
So und jetzt ist, also ich sage mal man trennt jetzt die landwirtschaftliche Fläche ist
bejagdbare Fläche, Waldfläche ist bejagtbare Fläche.
Also das ist zeitgleich.
Man muss im Grunde auf dieser bewirtschafteten Fläche eine Koexistenz mit
den Tieren managen.
Und aus Sicht des Land- oder Forstwirts, der brauch halt die Tiere nicht die Wildtiere.
Erstmal.
Die sind im Herzen oft auch anders.
Aber jetzt hat man auch wieder wirtschaftliche Konzentration also wo man früher
halt dem Landwirt in einer Latzhose gegenüberstand,
"Komm da drüben ey. Hier 50.
Alles ist das gut. Handschlag, gehen wir ein Bier trinken."
Da ist heute halt eine landwirtschaftliche Kapitalgesellschaft.
Da kommen Lohnunternehmer, die machen nichts anderes als einen
Maschinenpark in der Erntezeit quasi rund um die Uhr in Betrieb halten.
Hab schon Anrufe gekriegt, also da hatte ich eine halbe Stunde Fahrzeit ins Revier.
"In 20 Minuten kommen die mähen, hast du Zeit?"
Ey, geht's noch?
Um dann was zu tun?
Ja die Äcker abzustellen, wenn die Wildschweine drauf springen, dass man sie
halt eben vielleicht noch kriegen kann.
Wild- also Elektrozäune, Verteidigungsmaßnahmen, Elektrozäune, um ein paar
Quadratkilometer Feld ziehen,
zwei-, dreireihig.
Also sie haben es meistens zweireihig gemacht.
Jeden Tag abfahren, ob nicht
irgendwo ein Ast drauf gefallen ist, der den Stromkreis unterbricht oder
ein freundlicher Mitbewohner oder Mitbürger halt gesagt hat:
"Das will ich aber nicht in meiner Umwelt", und reißt das Ding kaputt.
Hat man ja auch
Mit dem Bauern diskutieren, Bejagungsschneisen einzuführen.
Ich meine, wenn ich einen Maisacker direkt an den Wald ran baue, dann sehe
ich überhaupt nicht mehr, wenn die Schweine vom Wald ins Feld wechseln.
Habe gar keine Chance sie zu kriegen.
Dann sind die schwuppdiwupp da.
Überhaupt Bioenergie Thema,
ich meine das ist eine Katastrophe für die Datenschutz.
Das ist eine Katastrophe.
Das Bioenergie-Thema ist?
Wir haben da Maiswüsten da draußen.
Das ist doch nichts anderes, als Rohstoff für
Bioenergieanlagen und ich sag mal so, Gegenden wie der Niederrhein, was so
klassische Wunderländer für Bodenbrüter,
ob jetzt Bergbau oder nicht waren, die sind halt mittlerweile komplett
vermaist und damit wird Lebensraum verschlechtert und für andere wieder verbessert.
Also ich meine ist ja auch immer so,
wir verschieben ja immer die Regler und das sind alles Dinge, die hat man
halt auf dem Radar und versucht irgendwie damit umzugehen.
Okay, das sind jetzt so Konfliktstellen,
die teilweise aus dem Vertraglichen sich heraus erwachsen,
beziehungsweise aus diesen Meta-Entscheidungen der Politik,
der Gesellschaft als solchen.
Wenn man jetzt mal nur so diesen eigentlichen Diskurs mit der Gesellschaft
über das Jagen an sich betrachtet:
Welche Konfliktstellen machen sich da auf?
Wie, denkst du, ist die Wahrnehmung sozusagen der Jagdwelt?
Also größtenteils unwissend.
Also es ist einfach ausgeblendet.
Also Ich jage ja relativ stadtnah, also am südlichen Ende von Köln habe ich viel viel
Kontakt als Jagdausübender mit der städtischen Bevölkerung gehabt
und es ist halt sehr oft so,
die gucken mich an, als hätte ich einen Bastrock an und einen Speer in der Hand.
Also eine Anekdote, die ich da immer gerne raushole,
wir liefen da also mit einem Freund, ich eine Flinte über der Schulter, er zwei Hunde
dabei augenscheinlich Jäger.
Ich hatte eine Ente dabei und ich nehme die jetzt schon einfach nicht mehr so am Hals
und lass die baumeln, was
eigentlich das Bequemste wäre, sondern ich neben den Kopf und pack den
unter eine Schwinge und trug die auf dem Unterarm wie ein Baby.
Dann sprang halt eine ältere Dame aus dem Gartentor wirklich
panisch auf mich zu und sprach:
"Um Himmels Willen! Die Ente, ist die verletzt?"
Die arme Ente.
Ja also ich meine total Parallelwelten
mit reichlich Abstand dazwischen.
Und ich schnappte auch nach Luft und: "Die ist tot."
Um Himmels willen was ist denn passiert?
Was tun wir jetzt jetzt?
Ja, ich habe drauf geschossen.
Aber warum tun Sie das?
Ja, weil ich dann esse, ich essen die dann und
ich töte die immer, bevor ich die esse immer.
Macht sich gut.
Ja und das ist so also diese Wertschöpfungsstufen.
Also irgendwer hat mal gesagt, bevor ich eine Wildsau erlege, habe ich 48 Stunden auf
einem Hochsitz verbracht.
Ich kenne auch Leute, die pennen da ein und wundern sich morgens über eine abgeräumte
Bühne da unten und umgedrehte Wiesen, die sie schlichtweg verschlafen haben.
Also wer will schon in der Holzkiste schlafen da draußen.
Was ist passiert, wenn man jetzt dran vorbei guckt, könnte einer drin sitzen
und gerade da machen.
Und ich meine das ist doch ein Erleben, das habe ich doch nicht mehr vor dem Kühlregal.
Hab doch keine Bindung mehr zu dem Tier,
was das Schnitzel geliefert hat.
Ich weißdoch gar nicht mehr, welchen Weg es gegangen ist.
Und diesen also auf einmal diese Pole ein des gleichen Fadens wieder so nahe
zusammenzukriegen, erzeugt bei vielen Menschen halt erstmal so ein befremden.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man damit ein bisschen sensibel umgeht, dann
aber auch so ein: "Achso. Ja, klar."
Also ich meine, wie will, ich meine man verstoffwechselt ja.
Wir hatten es ja vorhin.
Irgendwo muss es ja herkommen.
Also deshalb man kann sich dem ja nicht entziehen.
Man kann nicht nicht auf seine Umwelt einwirken.
Man kann nicht ohne
die Existenz anderer Lebewesen zu nehmen, seine eigene bestreiten.
Es geht eben nicht.
Und wenn der Gedanke wieder transportiert ist, dann ist alles gut.
Da gibt's ja natürlich auch so Bewegung, wie bei den Veganern.
Dass die so ein bisschen die These in den Raum stellen:
Man könnte das jetzt auch komplett tierfrei gestalten.
Also weiß jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt so die Kernthese ist.
So sehr verinnerlicht habe ich jetzt die Botschaften da auch nicht,
aber da gibt es ja eine gewisse Ablehnungshaltung.
Weiß nicht.
Ist das so eine Bevölkerungsgruppe,
oder so ein Trend in der Gesellschaft,
mit dem ihr häufiger in Konflikt geratet?
Oder rede ich mir das jetzt nur so herbei?
In der medialen Darstellung taucht es natürlich zunehmend auf.
Es ist halt gerade die Sau, die durchs Dorf getrieben wird.
Also, ich meine, die Kritik der Veganerbewegung orientiert sich,
wenn ich es richtig wahrnehme,
auch sehr viel mehr an diesem industriellen Prozess der Tierverarbeitung.
Ja, also es gibt solche und solche.
Landwirtschaft ist jetzt ein eigenes Thema, aber ich meine man kann drei
Schweine ganz schlimm halten und 1000 ganz liebevoll.
Also ich ist wieder so ein man
also der Begriff Massentierhaltung ist ja auch keiner,
der irgendwie definiert wäre.
So aber es gibt eben eine Fraktion der sogenannten Tierrechtler, die...
also ich vereinfache das jetzt ein bisschen und der Shitstorm mag über die
Kommentarspalte hereinbrechen.
Die fordern im Prinzip ein Lebensrecht für Tiere und man darf die
gar nicht mehr töten und auch gar nicht mehr nutzen.
Also es gibt da auch Vereine, die fordern ein Verbot der Nutztierhaltung
Vollständig also worunter dann auch ein Blindenhund fällt und auch eine Kuh,
die Milch gibt und alles Andere.
Und wie alles kann man es übertreiben.
Also es war ja ich glaube in Berlin war es sogar, haben Mütter ihre Kinder nicht mehr
gegen Masern impfen lassen mit dem Hinweis Impfstoffe werden ja in
Hühnereiern gezogen, die sind ja nicht vegan und dann gab es halt eben tote
Kinder und ob tote Kinder vegan sind, kann man jetzt auch wieder trefflich diskutieren.
Also will nur sagen, man kann ja ein Schieber drehen.
Anderes Ding ist, wenn ich
aufhöre tierische Produkte zu ernähren jetzt mal ganz egal,
ob Fleisch oder Milch und Eier.
Dann gehe ich aber auf eine Landwirtschaft, die wie auch mehrfach erwähnt,
ein Ziel einer Monokultur hat, ich gestalte also Lebensraum um.
Mir ist mal eine
Studie über den Weg gestolpert, dass der bei der Bewirtschaftung von
Ackerland 25 Mal mehr Tiere sterben, als auf einem Grünland, weil ich
natürlich Kleinnager, Insekten, keine Ahnung irgendwie was, wenn ich da
mit schwerem Gerät durchgehe, ist sowieso blöd und der Lebensraum ist
natürlich auch wieder an meine Zwecke als Mensch angepasst.
Andersherum brauche ich aber auch, um Ackerbau nach vorne zu treiben
schlichtweg die Düngung aus der Tierhaltung.
Also mache ich mehr pflanzliche Ernährung, brauche ich auch mehr Tiere,
<v jochenschumacherum den Dünger ranzukriegen.
Also irgendwo, wenn man mal anfängt es rund zu denken, dann ist eigentlich
immer irgendwo in der Mitte die Wahrheit.
Also ich bin jetzt auch keiner, der sich nur vom Steak ernährt und ich muss
auch nicht jeden Tag Fleisch haben, aber irgendwo in die Mitte.
Also was ich im Moment ganz gut finde, ist halt
so was wie Kuh-Leasing oder Tier-Leasing.
Also Bauern, die verkaufen, bevor die ein Schwein anschaffen oder eine Kuh, verkaufen
die im Grunde die Kuh an eine Familie.
Züchten die also päppeln die halt hoch
also durch die Mastphase durch
und dann kann diese Familie oder kriegt halt ein Viertel oder das ganze
Tier geht zum Schlachter als Wurst, Schinken, Schnitzel, keine Ahnung was für
den eigenen Verzehr und zwischendurch mit Bild und Webcam und keine Ahnung
was man da alles treiben kann.
Wie bei „Per Anhalter durch die Galaxis“,
wo dann die Kuh an den Restauranttisch kommt
und sich feilbietet.
Ja gut, aber wo weil einfach nur mal wieder den direkten Kontakt natürlich
herstellen und ich finde das eine ganz gute Idee.
Kann man auch mit Bäumen machen.
Kaufe das Brennholz für deine Enkel, wächst hier.
Oder kaufe den 10 Prozent der Strecke aus diesem Jagdrevier.
Um da vielleicht nochmal abzuschließen so mit diesem:
Die Jagd und die Gesellschaft.
Ich weiß da jetzt nicht so viel drüber.
Ich hab nur so –
Man hört halt immer mal wieder die eine oder andere Klage,
dass sozusagen jetzt auf rechtlicher Basis
auch Änderungen angestrebt werden,
die bei den Jägern nicht so populär sind.
Wie schön er sich ausdrücken kann.
Naja, deswegen mache ich das hier.
Was sind das sozusagen für Trends, die dort beklagt werden?
Betrieben wird es aus der einen Seite aus dem Naturschutzverbänden raus und
zum anderen eben aus diesen Tierschutz, aber eigentlich im Wesentlichen
Tierrechtsorganisation.
Und die grobe Idee dahinter ist, Natur Natur sein lassen,
was aber eigentlich nur bedeutet, dass man dem Elend letztlich
freien Lauf lässt.
Also ich sag mal so, ich hab so, was mich in der Seele treibt, ist aus der
Nutzung der Natur entsteht auch die moralische Verpflichtung zur Fürsorge
und wenn ich mir ein Reh oder einen Hirsch nehme,
ganz egal ob weiblich oder männlich,
und ich lass die natürlich altern, dann bedeutet das praktisch, dass die
ihre Zähne irgendwann so weit runter geschliffen haben, dass die die
Nahrung nicht mehr verwerten können.
Das heißt, die verhungern.
Und nach Rücksprache mit einem Tierarzt und einem
Professor für Nutztierethnologie in einer Person ist halt verhungern das
Schlimmste, was einem passieren kann.
Also das ist wirklich ein qualvoller, langsamer, langer Tod.
So man praktiziert
das bereits in manchem Nationalpark und es gibt halt Fälle, da hat man 30
Stück verhungerndes Wild halt irgendwie dabei beobachtet, wie sie das Efeu
von den Häusern im nächsten Dorf fressen oder auch später wirklich neben
den Wanderwegen verenden.
Und ich finde das wird unserer Zivilisation nicht gerecht.
Das hat nichts mehr mit dem Menschenbild zu tun, was wir glaube ich die meisten
von uns wenigstens mit sich herumschleppen.
Also ich habe da,
mich bewegt das und da bin ich wirklich froh, dieses Handwerk mit meinen
eigenen Händen ausüben zu können und so ein Tier  zu erlösen.
Dass es überhaupt so weit kommen muss, ist übrigens ein Drama.
Also ich kann einer großen, also Rotwild existiert in diesem Land ausschließlich
in Bewirtschaftungsbezirken und es muss erlegt werden, wenn es nur ein Huf
da raus setzt.
Das darf nicht frei ziehen.
Das ist ein Mythos.
Weil das rechtlich so ist? Oder weil?
Weil es rechtlich so ist.
So und wenn wir in Form von Grundrechten denken, da halte ich es auch mit
Kai Uwe Denker, dass ein Berufsjäger aus Namibia, der hat gesagt:
"Klar haben Tiere Rechte, die haben das Recht frei ihre Fährte zu ziehen."
Und Rotwild ist eine weit ziehende Wildart,
die über viele hunderte Kilometer manchmal ziehen.
Aber das Recht haben sie eigentlich nicht.
Das haben wir eben genommen durch die Inbesitznahme dieser Welt.
Wir Menschen haben die Verantwortung dafür.
Und ich finde, dann müssen wir auch dafür sorgen, dass die wenigstens in
einer stabilen Restpopulation erhalten bleiben und ihren Lebensraum haben.
Was mich jetzt noch mal interessieren würde:
Wie läuft denn eigentlich so eine Jagd ab?
Da gibt es ganz viele unterschiedliche Formen der Jagd.
Ja, das hätte ich jetzt sozusagen auch noch einschränkend hinzugefügt.
Von daher weiß ich jetzt auch gerade gar nicht,
welche Form der Jagd jetzt vielleicht an dieser Stelle
auch am interessantesten ist, zu beleuchten.
Auf der einen Seite hatten wir –
Ich mein, du bist ja im Prinzip als Einzeljäger unterwegs,
oder wie nennt man das dann?
Vielleicht
lass uns mal kurz die Technologie des Tötens noch einmal vorziehen.
Das gehört ja sozusagen dazu.
Ja weil das ist jetzt ein integraler Bestandteil der Jagd und sollte man
vielleicht auch nochmal handwerklich, so perfide das klingen mag,
einfach mal drüber reden.
Wir haben im Grunde drei Varianten, das ist
der Büchsenschuss, der Schrotschuss aus der Flinte oder die kalte Waffe,
also alles was Messer ist.
Also erschlagen tun wir...
doch bei Kaninchen kommt es auch manchmal vor.
Also Karnickelfangschlachten.
So und was ich also erstmal mit einem Büchsenschuss tue,
ist halt ein Projektil beschleunigen und ich möchte eine maximale
Energieübertragung auf den Wildkörper haben, weil ich da eine Zerstörung
herbeiführen möchte, die dafür sorgt, dass das Herz-Kreislauf-System zusammenbricht.
Zielpunkt ist also oberhalb des Zwerchfells wo Herz und Luge sitzen.
Weil das da die effektivsten Schäden erzeugt. Die Effizientesten.
Ein perfekter Treffer ist die Lunge zu treffen und das Herz intakt zu lassen.
Weil?
Weil das Herz nun dafür sorgt, dass das Blut in maximaler Geschwindigkeit aus
dem Körper raus gepumpt wird und damit der Tod eintritt
Herz treffen ist auch okay.
Beim Auftreffen selber hab ich schon eine Schockwirkung, also eine
Überreizung des Nervensystems, der Schock-Tod, ist ja eigentlich nichts
anderes als eine Überreizung des Nervensystems.
Das ist das, was beim Schrotschuss noch eintritt, aber dazu später.
Also vielleicht einfach noch mal in die Waffentechnik kurz rein.
Also so ein typisches Jagdkaliber meist geführt in Deutschland ist
.30 06 Springfield oder ich schieße eine 07 x 64, wenn auch sehr selten,
weil ich meistens wenn ich losgehe mit der Flinte jage.
Wenn ich eine Schussabgabe mache, hab ich halt ein Abbrand des Zündpulvers,
was für einen Druck vor meiner Nase von um die 4000 bar sorgt.
Also wenn man sich mal klarmacht, was ein Autoreifen so bei zwei bis drei Bar vielleicht
ausmacht, sind 4000 bar direkt vor der Nase...
denkt man nicht so gerne.
Ist eine Menge.
So dann ist da ein Projektil, das hat
bei diesem Kaliber ich sag mal so elf-zwölf Gramm,
das wird auf einer Entfernung von ungefähr 50 Zentimeter von Tempo null
auf über dreifacher Schallgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt.
Dann geht das da raus, parabelförmiger Flug.
Parabel kennst du dich ja aus.
Also verliert natürlich an Geschwindigkeit und sackt dann immer schneller runter.
Und jetzt hab ich erst mal von der Zieloptik
einen anderen Verlauf, nämlich eine Gerade wenn ich
durchs Zielfernrohr oder über Kimme und Korn gucke und mein Geschoss geht
erst einmal nach oben, kreuzt diese Visierlinie wie man es nennt und
fällt irgendwann wieder runter und kreuzt sie zum zweiten Mal,
um dann weiter abzusenken.
Und jetzt ist dieser zweite Punkt der Kreuzung, den
nennt man günstigste Einschussentfernung, was bedeutet das kann ich auf
den Packungen der Munition ablesen, dass ich auf definierten Entfernungen,
eine Schießstandentfernung ist typischerweise 100 Meter, zum Beispiel drei oder
vier Zentimeter hoch Schuss habe, um dann in der GEE also günstigste
Einschussentfernungen von zum Beispiel 180 Meter zu haben.
Das hat den Vorteil, dass ich halt wenn ich jetzt auf so eine Kammer nennen
die das oder ich sage immer ein bisschen schlapp auf den Maschinenraum
schießen Herz-Lungensysteme eben.
Meine Treffgenauigkeit, ich muss im Moment der Schussabgabe nicht ganz so
genau berechnen, wo ich hinkomme,
weil ist es kürzer, bin ich maximal diese vier Zentimeter zu hoch, bin ich halt
über meine GEE hinaus, bin ich halt zum Beispiel bis 200, 230 Meter oder was
immer noch maximal vier Zentimeter drunter.
Also deshalb diese Einschuss-Dinger.
Das Ganze verändert sich aber noch mit Höhe, also Hochgebirge ist anders.
Luftdruck ist anders.
Schieße ich hoch, schieße ich runter ist anders.
Diese ballistischen Teile mit Außenballistik ist das andere.
Was bei der Jagd jetzt wirklich komplett anders läuft, ist die sogenannte Zielballistik.
Also mein Geschoss trifft auf den Körper auf
und jetzt habe ich einen Einschuss.
Und was ich unbedingt haben will ist ein Ausschuss.
Weil ich dann Pirschzeichen habe am Anschuss.
Also läuft das Tier noch ein paar Meter,
kann ich anhand dieser
Pirschzeichen also dieser Gewebereste und auch des
Schweißes also der Blutkonsistenz
ziemlich genau sagen, wo habe ich es denn wirklich getroffen.
Also wo am Körper.
Wo am Körper.
Es gibt Leute, die haben Schnitthaarbücher also die können anhand der
Haarfarbe bestimmen,
in welcher Höhe, an welcher Stelle ungefähr das so gelaufen ist.
Du findest Knochensplitter.
Warum ist das überhaupt wichtig?
Ich meine, weil es dann unter Umständen weg ist und nicht komplett tot
und flüchtet noch eine Weile.
Ich habe schon von einem Rehbock gehört, da lag das Herz am Anschuss und
der ist noch über 200 Meter gelaufen.
Und ich habe...
Ich kann halt einfach daran entscheiden,
ist das eine einfache Todsuche,
sehe ich zum Beispiel an einem hellen blasigen Schweiß.
Das ist Lungenschweiß.
Kann ich sicher sein, das Ding ist tot oder ich habe zum Beispiel sehr
dunklen, körnigen Schweiß.
Der riecht nach Leber, das sind Leberschüsse oder darunter oder ich finde Panseninhalt.
Dann weiß, ich war ins Weiche unterhalb des Zwerchfells irgendwo.
Führt nicht unmittelbar zum Tod und tut vielleicht weh,
aber rennt in Panik davon.
Und das, unter Umständen, auch ziemlich lange.
Also sind jetzt alle Vorfälle, die will man nicht...
Ja, aber passiert.
Passiert und ich sage mal eine einfache Todsuche, die mach ich
vielleicht mit meinem eigenen Hund.
Wenn ich halt schon sehe, hmm
das aber jetzt doof, dann hole einen Schweißhundeführer.
Das heißt, man holt sich dann sozusagen nochmal extra einen anderen Hund
und einen anderen Hundeführer.
Warum? Weil das dann schwierig zu finden ist? Oder?
Weil ich zum Beispiel eine Verletzung habe, wo ich schon sehen kann, das Tier läuft
weit und es dauert lange und die Fährte hat einen Anspruch, die ich
mit meinen Mitteln überhaupt nicht hinkriege
Aber in dem Moment ist es natürlich das Ziel.
Also, man muss dieses Tier finden. Man lässt das jetzt nicht davonziehen.
Ja natürlich also das ist sowieso.
Wenn ich den Finger krumm mach, hab ich die volle Verantwortung.
Also das ist übrigens auch was ich jetzt so aus meinem Erleben.
Wenn ich in dem Moment, wo ich den Finger krumm mache, dann lastet ein Druck
auf meinen Schultern, der ist nicht zu ertragen.
Und wenn ich seh, das liegt und alles ist gut, dann macht das huuuu und
und das fällt ab
und alles ist gut.
Und wenn das nicht ist, dann ist zittern.
Dann ist natürlich zittern.
Also ich hatte auch mal so einen Fall, auf einen Rehbock geschossen,
der kurz über so eine kleine Anhöhe ist und man geht nicht sofort hinterher.
Also Jägersprache: "Der geht ins Wundbett" und dann
stirbt er und deshalb lässt man ihn in Ruhe.
Wenn man die nochmal aufmüdet zu früh, dann schießt wieder das Adrenalin rein und
man verlängert die Fluchten.
Was heißt aufmüdet?
Also  wieder auf die Läufe.
Also die flüchten wieder, die die kämpfen ja um ihr Leben und übrigens manchmal
auch sehr wehrhaft also gerade was Schwarzwild also Wildschweine angeht und
man will die in Ruhe verenden lassen, das ist so die typische Zigarettenlänge
sagt man dann, bevor man dann wirklich gucken geht, ist alles ok.
Und man hat in den meisten Fällen ist alles okay.
Und manchmal ist halt doof.
Und dann ist der Schweißhundeführer also es gibt ein Netz.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, aber ich glaube so um die 1000 Schweißhundestationen
bundesweit von ehrenamtlichen Leuten, die sich im Grunde zu
jeder Tages- und Nachtzeit aus dem Bett klingeln lassen
und dann solche Nachsuchen machen.
Also einerseits durch solche Fehlschusse verursacht, aber auch zu einem sehr
großen Teil durch Verkehrsunfälle verursacht.
Also ist wieder so ein "hinterherräumen" hinter der Zivilisation.
Ich habe neulich ein Bericht in
Bern, im Kanton Bern, ist die Anzahl der verursachten Nachsuchen durch
Verkehr siebenmal so hoch wie die durch Jagd.
Stimmt. Was für ein Aspekt. Den habe ich noch gar nicht bedacht.
Das heißt auch an der Stelle kommen dann diese Leute zum Einsatz.
Also eine krasse Geschichte war ein Verkehrsunfall, da wird ein Schweißhundeführer,
also hannoverscher Schweißhund oder bayerischer Gebirgsschweißhund
oder die dritte Rasse sind die erzgebirgischen Dachsbracken, die als
Schweißhunde-Spezialisten eben geführt werden.
Eben Experten auf der Fährte.
Die gehen hinterher auf so seiner Fährte, die mit
kleinsten Spuren,
also stell dir vor, ein verwelktes Herbstlaub
und da kommt jetzt ein Tropfen Blut drauf und geronnenes Blut wird ja eher
bräunlich also das verliert ja das leuchtende Rot sehr schnell beim Gerinnen und da
überhaupt ein Auge für zu haben, so was zu sehen.
Oder da hängt mal ein Stück
Fell und drei Haare irgendwo also da ist wieder so eine ganz andere Schärfung,
der Sinne mit verbunden.
Und dann geht man diesem Hund hinterher und ja ich meine so ein
Wildschwein geht ja auch nicht um die
Brombeerdickungen drum herum, sondern mittendurch.
Der Hund geht dann auch mittendurch und ich auch.
Weil, man darf auch den Hund nicht verlieren.
So und jetzt hast du wieder erstmal der Schweißhundeführer kommt vor Ort.
Und was ist denn überhaupt passiert?
Der ist erstmal angewiesen auf die
Informationen, die ihm der Jäger oder der Autofahrer in dem Fall halt liefert.
Und geht halt hinterher und denkt: "Naja wohl aufgrund der Angaben müsste eigentlich finden."
Und dann war das aber gar nicht so, weil man irrt sich, gerade so in der
Dämmerung oder wenn es dunkel wird.
Da ist ein Erdhaufen, der fängt auf einmal an sich zu bewegen.
Also in der Dunkelheit auf dem Hochsitz sitzen und einfach nur mal
aufs Smartphone gucken.
Danach braucht das Auge wieder drei Minuten, um sich an die Dunkelheit zu gewöhnen.
Also auch Technik-Foo.
Ganz vorsichtig damit.
Podcast hören auf dem Hochsitz, ja ist unterhaltsam,
ich kriege aber nichts mehr mit.
Weil, man muss eigentlich komplett eintauchen in diese Umgebung.
Optisch, akustisch. Was noch?
Ja in die Psyche in die Gewohnheiten der Tiere.
Also in all diese Dinge.
In den Hormonhaushalte also wenn Fortpflanzungszeiten sind.
Wie verhalten die sich?
Ist auch ein Fiebern.
Kommt das Tier nochmal über den Winter, sehe ich ihn wieder?
Also ein Hirsch reif
werden zu lassen, heißt den 12, 13, 14 Jahre zu begleiten auf seinem Lebensweg.
Ist eine Verbindung,
wo ich schon manchen gehört habe, der hat gesagt:
"Ich kann den nicht erlegen."
Fragen ihren besten Freund.
Verständlich.
Das sind also das ist ja auch etwas mütterliches zu gucken, dass
denen das Bettchen immer schön gemacht
ist also Lebensraum intakt und so.
Gut aber zurück zur Nachsuche.
Also man geht da hinterher und weiß
nicht, was einen erwartet.
Das hab ich irgendwann komme ich,
ich sehe unterwegs auch immer Wundbetten wo die sich nieder getan haben.
Da ist dann halt zerdrückt.
Da ist dann halt wieder Schweiß
oder irgendwas zu finden.
Der Hund verweist die auch, zeigt die an.
Und irgendwann höre ich es
vorne halt rascheln und dann schnalle ich den Hund
also lasse ihn von der Leine.
Und der Hund hat den Job dann hinterher zu
gehen und das Tier zu stellen also am Ort zu binden,
dass ich als Jäger halt hinterherkomme mit meinen vergleichsweise
beschränkten Möglichkeiten und daran komme.
So wenn der Hund aber drum herum
springt, in dem Tempo wie Hunde das können, kann ich nicht schießen ohne
meinen eigenen Hund zu gefährden.
Kriegt man den Hund dann abgezogen?
Seltener, weil wenn ich den abziehe, haut das Schwein wieder ab
oder welches Tier auch immer es ist.
Heißt dann halt nicht selten, ich muss da von Hand dran.
Also ich eine
Wildsau, gerade die Keiler also die Keiler haben vorne diese Waffen
also die man so als lange Hauer kennt und es gibt Geschichten von
Ärzten, die im Wald verblutet sind.
Die gehen zwischen die Beine, hauen einmal links und rechts,
sind die Schlagadern durch, dann bist du so schnell blutleer, da kannste gar nicht gucken.
Da gibt's wieder Sauenschutzhosen, die das weitgehend...
Kostet 250-300 Euro so eine Hose.
Aber eine lohnende Investition.
Und die Bachen, die weiblichen, die kauen halt gerne also die
beißen und die kauen dir die
Muskeln und Sehnen durch.
Hatten wir mal so ein Fall im Revier, das war auch großes Hurra.
So und jetzt musst da von Hand ran
also du guckst halt irgendwie, der Hund beschäftigt das,
dass die Wildsau halt mit dem Hund beschäftigt ist und im richtigen Moment
hintendran mit der einen Hand halt den Hinterlauf genommen, hochgezogen und mit dem
anderen muss ich mit dem Messer halt vorne tödlich in die Kammer rein.
Wenn ich aber einfach rein hacke, treffe ich eine Rippe.
Wenn ich die Rippe treffe,
komme ich nicht in den Maschinenraum.
Also muss ich irgendwie drauf, zurückführen eine Lücke zu finden,
rein stoßen und aufdrehen, weil die Lunge ein Unterdruck System ist, dass die
Lunge kollabiert und in sich zusammenfällt.
Also diese eine Geschichte, die ich gerade absprach.
Das Schwein hat man hinterher gewogen das waren 163 Kilo.
163 Kilo die um ihr Leben kämpfen
und wir haben jemanden, der ehrenamtlich also mit kleinen Unterstützung, die
kriegen tausend Euro im Jahr, 1000 Euro im Jahr so lächerlich, die dann
diesen Tieren hinterher gehen, um die dann zu erlösen, weil sonst die
verrecken qualvoll.
Diese Schweißhundeführer sind dann auch diejenigen,
die diesen Todesstoß setzen?
Also die übernehmen sozusagen diese komplette Entsorgung.
Oder „Entsorgung“ ist das falsche Wort. Endbegleitung.
Die Verwertung ist dann noch mal wieder eine andere Nummer, können wir auch noch einsteigen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Will nur mal...
Also ich weiß
das ist dramatisch und musst du wahrscheinlich explizit an die Sendung
hängen und mal den Schalter an machen.
Ich meine, so ist das Leben einfach.
Nur man kriegts halt normalerweise nicht mit.
Deswegen wollte ich ja auch da drüber sprechen.
Ja, ich wollte auch mal offen drüber reden.
Das sind da eben auch Risiken, die man der Tierwelt zumutet wenn man mit dem
Auto oder mit dem Zug fährt.
Das passiert und das ist eben immer diese Grenze zwischen Zivilisation und der
verbliebenen Wildnis, die da draußen noch auf diesem Niveau tobt.
Also ist auf jeden Fall...
Ich kann mir eigentlich kaum etwas vorstellen, wofür man mehr Hintern in
der Hose haben muss.
Man muss da wirklich einen kühlen Kopf behalten.
Also wenn ich da nicht die Kontrolle über mich selbst und das
Zusammenspiel mit dem Hund und wann tue ich wann was und wann greife ich
halt wirklich zu
und wie setze ich meinen Stoß.
Wenn da etwas schief geht, dann bin ich selber ernsthaft in Gefahr.
Oder mein Hund auch.
Es gibt Fälle da wurden Hunde erschossen weil die hinter der Sau einfach
nicht sichtbar waren.
Oder vielleicht auch im Kampf mit dem Tier.
Weiß nicht wie. Ich mein, der Hund wiegt ja nicht 160 Kilo.
Nee nee, klar.
Also die müssen ja auch sehr flink auf den Läufen sein.
Also ich will auch gar nicht, dass mein Hund in den Nahkampf geht.
Der soll halt drum rumtanzen und kläffen und verbellen
Also blinken.
Eindruck schaffen, sozusagen.
Ja und da ist wieder so ein also Hund und Mensch auf der Jagd ist was Einzigartiges.
Mit was für Tieren hast du so gemeinhin zu tun?
Also wenn es wirklich zum Abschuss kommt, was ist das dann meistens?
Also ich habe bis jetzt Wildschwein, Reh, unzählige Enten, ein paar Fasane,
ein paar Hasen, viele Kaninchen.
Und so die primären Gründe für die Abschüsse waren,
dass man festgestellt hat, dass diese Tiere,
also entweder die spezifischen Tiere, also die Individuen,
oder halt diese Art dezimiert werden muss, um diese Lebensraumgestaltungen,
die man dort vorhat, umsetzen zu können.
Da ist wieder so ein also diese Zweckbindung da ist wieder so ein Ding.
Also wenn genug davon da sind, dann glaub ich,
darf ich auch welche entnehmen, damit ich sie essen kann
Also das ist der Anfang von Allem.
Also das Jagdrecht ist eigentlich vom Ursprung, von wieder jetzt mal kurzer Sprung
nach ganz hinten, ein jedermanns Recht.
Weil es existenzsichernd einfach ursprünglich immer gewesen ist und jede
Einschränkung davon ist ja eigentlich ein Preis, den wir der Zivilisation
zahlen, dafür dass wir sie haben.
So und wenn ich da draußen eine intakte Population habe, die reproduktionsfähig
ist, dann spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass ich auch abschöpfe.
Also erstens, weil ich sie essen kann und zweitens, weil ich sie damit ja auch
gesund erhalte von wegen Infektionsdruck und diese Dinge.
Oder anders rum.
Ich habe zum Beispiel den Fuchs, der es flächendeckend gegen Tollwut
geimpft worden, weil der Mensch halt gesagt hat: "Tollwut ist für uns als
Gattung eine so große Bedrohung,
deshalb nehmen wir diesen Eingriff per Medikament vor."
Jetzt streiten sich die Experten,
ist die Fuchspopulation um den Faktor drei bis zehn angewachsen.
Mehr Füchse futtern natürlich mehr Nahrung.
Gibt ihm einerseits natürlich ein Druck in die Städte
also man sagt mittlerweile leben in den Städten
mehr Füchse als draußen auf dem Land.
Ich sehe so viele Füchse hier, das ist echt enorm in Berlin. Ganz oft.
Und andererseits haben wir aber ein Artenschutzthema, weil Bodenbrüter
also alles, was Boden brütet, nicht nur die jagdbaren Arten ganz ausdrücklich.
Also erstmal kommt nicht gefressen werden und dann kommt schöner wohnen.
Nicht weit weg hier in Brandenburg, Sachsen-Anhalt gibt's das Großtrappen-Projekt.
Die haben von einer minimal Population von 48 Tieren, 1997 glaub ich wurden die
gezählt, die es in Deutschland überhaupt noch gibt.
Haben die durch eine Lebensraumverbesserung und eine
konsequente Raubwildbejagung
jetzt wieder 200 Exemplare hochgepäppelt.
So und wir haben erstmal den
Fuchs, der natürlich sich durch Immunisierung extrem vermehrt hat.
Dann kommt der Waschbär rein, dann irgendwann haben mal irgendwelche
Pelztierfarm-Gegner aus der Tierrechtsszene in Sachsen-Anhalt eine
Farm aufgemacht.
Die kommen auch noch da drauf und der Marderhund, der wandert
von Osten auch noch ein
und die kommen alle auf die gleiche Nahrungsgrundlage.
Welche Pelztiere?
Amerikanischer Nerz.
Mink nennt man die.
Die sind so einen halben Meter groß.
Die hat man mal eben zu Bekleidungszwecken gezüchtet.
Und durch die Befreiung sozusagen ausgewildert.
Ja als Neozoen nennt man die, Arten die hier halt nicht in die also in die Welt gehören.
Und das ist natürlich alles ein kompletter Druck, der dann halt eben auf
bedrohte Arten ausgeübt wird.
Nochmal zu diesem „du nimmst dir das“. Ich meine...
Du hast sozusagen Jagdrecht jetzt in einem bestimmten Gebiet auf Basis
eines solchen Pachtvertrages und das heißt,
im Prinzip, kannst du da erst einmal tun und lassen, was du willst,
sofern du deine Vertragsverpflichtungen dort auch erfüllst.
Ja und im Rahmen der Gesetzgebung natürlich.
Ja selbstverständlich. Klar.
So. Aber dann kannst du eben auch dieses Gebiet nutzen,
quasi zur eigenen Verpflegung. Das tust du auch.
Das ist der einzige Ertrag, den ich daraus eben kriege.
Also mich selber zu verpflegen oder auch das Wild zu vermarkten.
Weil bezahlt kriegst du dafür sozusagen nichts, dass du da jagst.
Nein ich nenne das gerne kostenpflichtiges Ehrenamt.
Und das heißt, es gehört dann auch so ein Teil dazu,
zu dieser Ökonomisierung für einen selbst.
Dass diese Tätigkeit sich auch in gewisser Hinsicht für einen bezahlt macht.
Ja also bezahlt macht sie sich nie.
Das ist ganz sicher nichts, womit man irgendwie Geld verdienen kann.
Also im Normalfall auf jeden Fall nicht und
das ist einfach nur, das steht den Kosten eben ein
Stück weit entgegen, aber im Normalfall sicher nicht vollständig
und schon gar nicht mit Gewinn.
Ja. Und was man jetzt sozusagen – Ich meine, wenn –
Was wäre denn jetzt so dein primäres Ziel?
Was bietet sich sozusagen an?
Also so Rehe, Hirsche et cetera, ist ja nun schmackhaftes Fleisch.
Ja, Tauben ist z.B.
auch toll, kann man super Suppen draus machen.
Aber man isst ja nicht so einen ganzen Hirsch.
Schafft man kaum.
Also ich hab mal Rotwild-Schmaltier gekauft.
Man nennt die Kalb im ersten Jahr Schmaltier oder Spießer im zweiten Jahr
und ab dann sind es dann Hirsche oder Alttiere im weiblichen Fall.
Und das hatte aufgebrochen, also ohne Innereien, am Haken 73 Kilo.
Das hab ich mittags um halb zwei bin ich losgefahren,
dann haben wir es den Pullover ausgezogen und grob zerteilt in Keulen,
Rücken, Blätter also Vorderleute bis zur Schulter, Träger also Hals.
Und dann bin ich nach Hause gefahren, da war ich um halb sieben also eine
halbe Stunde Fahrzeit ungefähr und dann hatte ich um halb neun die erste
Keule ausgelöst und fertig.
Und das ging eigentlich auch nur in meiner Wohnung,
weil es war gerade kalt draußen und der Balkon ist direkt an meiner Küche.
Also so hatte ich einen Kühlraum
und um hab ich eben da um halb neun-neun hab ich die Panik
geschoben angesichts des Restberges und hab mein Freund angerufen und dann
haben wir wissen morgens um eins darum gemacht und das ganze Zeug halt
küchenfertig zubereitet.
Und das heißt dann halt eben ja auch wirklich eine möglichst vollständige Verwertung.
Also zum Beispiel
die Bauchdecke ist Muskulaturfleisch dran und Abschnitte da mache ich
noch ein Gehacktes draus, kannste astreine Bolognese oder Frikadellen von machen.
Man kriegt auch eine Menge Kücheninspiration, sozusagen.
Ich kenne Leute, die machen Schinken aus Kaninchen
Geht alles, man kann Wurst selber machen.
Also das ist alles möglich.
Also das ist ja bis zum Verzehr hinten mit Kochen und Zubereiten
um allem Trallala...
Aber du bist ja nicht gezwungen, das alles unbedingt selber zu machen?
Nee, bin ich nicht, aber ich finde jeder Jäger sollte das wenigstens mal erlebt haben.
Also was ich auf jeden Fall machen muss, ist aufbrechen.
Wenn ich ein Tier erlegt hab,e also nehmen wir jetzt mal ein Reh, weil es eine sehr
häufige Art ist, hab ich vor zwei Wochen noch gehabt,
dann kommt der Organismus zum Stillstand durch Tod
und im Grunde beginnt dann die Verwesung.
Das erste was ich tue, ist halt Bauchdecke öffnen.
Machen was mal detailliert, weil es so schön ist.
Also bei männlichen Tieren ist der erste Schnitt ist Schniedel ab
Warum?
Also die sind ja an der Bauchdecke, ja weil ich sonst einfach die Bauchdecke nicht ordentlich öffnen kann...
Ah, aus Platzgründen.
Das ist so eine Hautfalte
also ich muss links anfassen und dann den Schnitt halt nach hinten in
Richtung Keulen setzen, um den Schniedel und dann hintenrum halt auch noch
die Hoden mit abzunehmen, damit ich offen bin.
So dann mache ich einen kleinen Schnitt,
dass ich mit zwei Fingern also Zeige- und Mittelfinger der linken Hand
halt unter die Bauchdecke komme und zwischen den Fingern die Klinge von
innen quasi führen kann, weil ich die Innereien nicht verletzen möchte.
Das Schlimmste ist Blase und Galle, wenn die halt da rein laufen, dann hat
das geschmackliche Auswirkungen.
Also Urin und Gallenflüssigkeit ist nicht gut.
Was ich auch nicht unbedingt möchte, ist so Mageninhalt drin.
Ist nicht mehr ganz so schlimm, aber ich will natürlich auch keine Verkotung haben.
Und dann fühl ich halt die Klinge bis zum Brustbein erstmal hoch und dann öffnet sich das.
Das Ganze ist übrigens wichtig, dass relativ zeitnah zumachen,
weil sonst verhitzt es, weil die ganzen Verdauungsvorgänge mit den Bakterien
dann durch die Magen- und Darmwände
diffundieren ins Wildbret hinein und das merkt man auch geschmacklich.
Das heißt irgendwo mitten in der Pampa steht man und macht das klar.
Also ich häng die dafür gerne an den Hinterläufen an den Baum.
Damit die ja erst mal so aussuppen können.
Ja Aussuppen das eine, das andere...
Dass man überall rankommt, sozusagen.
Ja, Arbeitshöhe muss ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen Ergonomie muss ja auch sein.
Und dann kommt mir das alles entgegen und im Grunde ist wie früher in der
Feuerzangenbowle, das ist halt eine Maschine und die hat vorne und hinten Loch.
Hast halt vorne natürlich irgendwie über Speiseröhre, wo es reinkommt, hast du halt musst
gucken, dass das nicht in den Körper also
man kann die verknoten, da gibt's auch Techniken für, was ich persönlich aber
nicht anwende und am anderen Ende, wo die Rückstände wieder rauskommen,
da hab ich das Problem, dass der Enddarm durch den Beckenknochen
hindurch führt und ich kann jetzt nicht ohne.
Also ich kann da jetzt mit Messer nicht einfach drin rumfuhrwerken,
weil sonst hab ich immer die Gefahr, den Enddarm zu verletzen und dann halt
ja die Scheiße im Tier zu haben, um es beim Namen zu nennen.
Und jetzt gibt's halt zwei Varianten, die eine ist halt Schloss aufbrechen,
also dafür gibt's bei ??? (?) Tieren wird quasi der Knochen vorne immer härter,
da brauche ich eine Säge, bei Jungtieren kann ich mit einem Messer außen drauf drücken
und dann halt quasi das Becken brechen, dass der Enddarm frei liegt
und die andere Variante, die ist noch schöner.
Die heißt im Grunde, ums Weitloch hinten rum aufschärfen, wie man sagen.
Also hier Ringel
rund drum, zieh quasi den Darm nach oben raus, bis das vollständig frei ist
und der sich vollständig gelöst hat und kann ganz
dann den Rest nach unten wieder gut rausnehmen.
Dafür gibt's übrigens tolle Plugs,
also es gibt so Stöpsel, die kann man wirklich reinziehen,
um das raus zunehmen und drunter abzuschärfen.
Also gibt es Spezialwerkzeug für.
Logischer Fortschritt. Hurra!
Ja, aber ich meine, das sind ja auch so Sachen,
da macht man sich ja nie einen Kopf darüber.
Da denkt man immer so: „Piffpaff“ und dann war’s das irgendwie,
aber man muss ja dann sozusagen auch mit den Konsequenzen leben.
Also nicht nur jetzt hier mit dieser Nachpirsch
und den damit verbundenen Gefahren und Konsequenzen,
sondern eben auch die Zuführung einer Verwertung.
Und die jetzt ganz unabhängig davon, ob du das jetzt selber ist oder nicht.
Das muss ja jetzt erst mal gemacht werden.
Und die Überreste, die verbleiben dann am Ort?
Kommt kommt drauf an..
Also Standard ja.
Lassen wir erstmal da die Innerei.
Also die Leber ist zum Beispiel,
Leber und Herz ist kleines Jägerrecht,
kriegt der Erleger.
Also versuch mal eine Rehleber zu kaufen, du wirst scheitern.
Also kriegst du quasi gar nicht
und ja freuen sich die Füchse zum Beispiel.
Ist auch nicht so schlimm.
Das verwertet sich von alleine und das ziemlich schnell.
Hat jetzt noch ein kleiner Ausflug bleifreier Munition.
Es gibt Magenmilieus, zum Beispiel bei Greifvögeln
also hier Adler ist ein Thema, wo Blei sich im
Magenmilieu auflöst und dann den Vogel vergiftet.
Dem hätte man ganz einfach Herr werden können,
indem man sagt, Aufbruch mitnehmen.
Und in die Biogasanlage zum Beispiel, wo so was dann reinkommt.
Was man aber getan hat, ist man versucht gerade
eine Pflicht zur bleifreien Munition einzuführen.
Also es ist noch nicht der Fall, sozusagen.
Also Munition enthält in der Regel Blei?
Ja.
Blei hat halt einfach den entscheidenden Vorteil auf einer kleinen
Fläche eine hohe Masse zu konzentrieren also spezifisches Gewicht.
Und es hat den Vorteil relativ gut verformbar zu sein.
Also nochmal zurück in die Zielballistik.
Ich stoße auf und jetzt hab ich zwei Typen von Geschossen,
ein Zerlegungs- oder Deformationsgeschoss oder auch
Mischtypen gibt's wie in Haarmantel.
Und dann Pilzen die auf und mein Ziel ist eigentlich ein
möglichst hohes Geschossrestgewicht zu haben, weil dann ist natürlich
möglichst wenig Splitterwirkung im Wildbret übrig.
Für den Verzehr hinterher.
Wenn ich jetzt auf Bleiersatzmaterialien gehe,
dann geht ein Rattenschwanz an Problemen los.
Erstens sind alternative Materialien haben ein geringeres Gewicht.
Wenn ich die gleiche Energie auf die gleiche Entfernung auf den
Körper auftragen will, muss ich die Geschwindigkeit erhöhen
Also mehr Sprengkraft in der Munition haben.
Ja im Zünd-Ding und ich sage mal durch geringeres Gewicht
beschleunigt die natürlich auch besser
also bis zum Austritt aus der Mündung.
Jetzt habe ich aber den zweiten Teil, dass die Formbarkeit
eines Nicht-Blei-Geschosses
in aller Regel schlechter ist, weil die Materialien härter sind.
Das heißt, das Ansprechverhalten im Körper ist halt schlechter.
Die dieses Aufpilzen passiert später.
und das kann bei kleineren Tieren dazu führen, dass die quasi wie eine
Vollmantel-Munition durchgehen und
nicht den erwünschten Erfolg zeigen wie
ein Bleigeschoss es tut.
Das heißt, sie werden einfach nur so durchlöchert,
aber diese Auftreffwirkung ist einfach nicht so groß.
Genau also die Energieübertragung auf den Körper,
das ist ja eigentlich das, was man will.
Und es gibt Geschosse, die sind mittlerweile ganz gut,
aber die verlieren natürlich
auf Distanz auch wieder schneller Energie,
also je länger die in der Luft sind,
ist ein leichteres Geschoss natürlich leichter abzubremsen
als ein Schwereres.
Und das Ganze ist letztendlich nichts anderes als eine Verschiebung
vom Tierschutzgedanken, weil ich ja schnell und unmittelbar töten will,
hin zu Umweltschutzgedanken oder wo ich jetzt eben diesen
Eintrag von Blei nicht mehr haben will.
Also das ist eigentlich die Güterabwägung, die da läuft.
Und die generelle Verpflichtung auf bleifreien Munition
heißt eigentlich, ein flächendeckenden Tierversuche einführen.
Es kommt nämlich sehr darauf an.
Also ich kann ein relativ großes Geschoss
mit viel Geschossgewicht leichter durch eine bleifreie
Alternativkonstruktion ersetzen,
als zum Beispiel eine Kleinkaliber-Geschoss.
Und deshalb ist immer so ein kommt drauf an
und es gibt auch wieder bleifreie Geschosse,
die sind nur auf eine Entfernung von 50/60 Meter wirksam.
Also danach haben die einfach so viel Energie verloren,
dass die hinterher nicht mehr
das nötige Ergebnis erzielen.
Oder Ansprechverhalten worüber man sich in
der Jägerschaft eigentlich bisher wenig Gedanken gemacht hat.
Also da hat mal jemand auf ballistische,
nee forensische Seife geschossen, wo die
maximale Ausdehnung der Kaverne erhalten bleibt.
Also schießt man auf Gelatine, schwabbelt ja alles wieder zurück
und ich muss halt sehr mühsam gucken, wie denn die Energieverteilung war.
Mit so einem Seifenblock sieht man sozusagen ganz genau,
wo sich überhaupt Kraft ausgewirkt hat.
Es wird einfach nur so ausgehöhlt und bleibt stabil drumherum.
Genau, ja.
Forensische Seife.
Ja, was es alles gibt.
Ich lerne hier irgendwie alle 30 Sekunden gerade einen neuen Begriff.
Ja und das ist eben,
also ich würde mir an der Stelle ein sehr viel genaueres "kommt drauf an" wünschen.
Wir waren ja jetzt eigentlich bei dem Ausweiden, Aufbrechen
und der Frage: Was macht man dann sozusagen jetzt mit dem Tier?
Also, die Reste bleiben vor Ort,
es gibt diese Probleme mit der Bleimunition.
In dem Moment, wo man Munition eingesetzt hat
und irgendwie den Anlass hat zu glauben,
dass das sozusagen im Rest verblieben ist,
müsste man es eigentlich mitnehmen.
Oder sollte man es eigentlich mitnehmen? Oder?
Ja also zumindest in Gebieten in denen halt solche Gefahren bestehen.
Also hier Brandenburg, Meck-Pomm runter, wo Adler vorkommen sind.
Das ist vor allem einem Problem für Vögel, sozusagen. Okay.
So. Aber so oder so, hat man dann
sozusagen das eigentlich verbliebene Fleisch, sozusagen,
der nutzbare, also für uns zumindest nutzbare Teil.
Wenn man das jetzt nicht alles selber eintopft, gleich verwertet,
alle seine Freunde einlädt, oder den Tiefkühler bedient,
gibt's ja sicherlich auch noch so eine Verwertungskette
über Restaurants oder andere Unternehmen.
Ja es gibt Wild-Händler, die ja
die als Zwischenhändler halt fungieren also insbesondere,
wenn man Druckjagden, ist ein Begriff, den hatten wir jetzt auch schon öfter,
also sind im Grunde, man versucht den Abschuss auf Schalenwild in
Schalenwild ist?
Alles, was Hufe hat also Rehwild, Rotwild,
Damwild, Muffelwild, Schafe sind das.
Also an einem Tag zu konzentrieren,
also man stellt großflächig im Revier Schützen aus,
oft auch Revier übergreifend,
dass benachbarte Reviere sich da absprechen.
Man geht mit niederläufigen Stöberhunden rein,
die Spurlaut sind vor allem also die,
sobald die eine Witterung haben,
fangen die an zu klopfen und dann denkt sich dein Wild:
"Ach, wieder so ein Nervling. Ich gehe mal auf die Läufe."
Und das Ziel ist, dass das Wild halt möglichst
langsam und relativ vertraut vor den Schützenstand kommt,
um sich der Erregung hinzugeben.
Also „auf die Läufe“, das sind sozusagen die normalen Laufwege der Tiere?
Die Läufer sind die Beine
Achso, also die Hunde treiben die Tiere raus.
Ja sozusagen also ist eine Beunruhigungsjagd, wie man auch sagt.
Okay, gut.
Also man macht ein bisschen Palaver, die Tiere merken, heute anders als gestern,
träume ich mal lieber.
Die gehen typischerweise über ihre Wege,
die nennt man Wechsel,
Wechsel- und Rückwechsel sind wieder da kommt einer zurück.
Und dann stellt man eben an diesen
strategischen Punkten auch auf Basis der
Erfahrungen von vorherigen Jagden,
baut man da Drückjagdstände also erhöhte Stände,
was aus Sicherheitsgründen auch wichtig ist und guckt halt eben,
dass man innerhalb dieser wenigen Stunden den Großteil des jährlichen
Abschusses hinkriegt.
Bin Alternative zu.
Ich jage das ganze Jahr immer mal wieder.
Versucht man darüber also das ist zumindest die Ur-Idee,
das Jahr über weitgehend Ruhe zu halten und
den Tieren auch in Frieden zu lassen.
So wird manchmal aber auch kombiniert
und dann wird es auch wieder hässlich also
so eine Drückjagd ist eine sehr scharfe Waffe,
mit der man sehr verantwortungsvoll umgehen muss.
Scharf, weil sie sehr effizient ist sozusagen.
Die Tiere relativ wenig Chancen haben, dem zu entgehen.
Sie ist sehr effizient und deshalb mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Also wenn ich als Schütze wohin geh und da ist eine Drückjagd,
dann will ich wissen, wer betreut das Revier,
was ist den Rest des Jahres da gelaufen,
wie ist die Bejagungstrategie, wie gehen die mit Forst
und sonst was um also ich nerv und will Fragen beantwortet haben,
weil ansonsten ist das schnell Massaker
und da wird auch Matsche produziert.
Also wenn man zum Beispiel mit hochläufigen Hunden jagt,
dann gehen die halt so hart ans Wild, dass...
Was heißt „hochläufig“ beim Hund?
Lange Beine, schnelle...
Lange Beine macht schnelle Hunde
also ein Dackel ist eigentlich da ideal.
Also man nimmt kleine Terrier,
die auf jeden Fall nicht unmittelbar am Wild jagen,
sondern eigentlich nur so viel Unruhe machen, dass es sich in Bewegung setzt.
Und wenn ich einen Hund habe, der am Wild jagt,
dann hab ich halt hohen Adrenalinausstoß.
Ich mache das Tier sehr schnell,
wenn ich überlege ist das Wildbret auch
gar nicht mehr zu verwerten
und ich habe natürlich auch Unfälle, dass da Risse passieren.
Also die Hunde wollen auch haben, die Frage nicht.
Wodurch ist geregelt, wie viele Tiere man überhaupt erlegen darf?
Ja meistens ist es eher ein Muss ehrlich gesagt,
also gerade im Schalenwildbereich ist es eher ein Muss.
Es gibt eher eine Vorgabe: so und so viele müssen.
Wodurch kommt diese Vorgabe?
Ich meine letztlich basiert das doch alles auf der eigenen Analyse.
Oder gibt es tatsächlich...
Hat was hat was mit Zielrichtung.
Ja natürlich ein Stück weit
und man einigt sich dann mit dem
Grundeigentümer was immer der da tut und welche Ziele er verfolgt.
Aber auch nur mit dem.
Also, es gibt jetzt keine behördliche Verfügung?
Doch doch gibt's auch noch.
Also es gibt auch noch behördliche Abschusspläne.
Ich sage mal es ist halt eben so, dass ich als Revierbetreiber,
hoffentlich korrigiert mich jetzt keiner,
aber auf jeden Fall ein Abschussplan aufstelle, den ich auch
abstimme mit meinem Grundeigentümer
und den reiche ich bei der Unteren Jagdbehörde ein
und die genehmigen den dann.
Und ich muss hinterher auch meine Strecken wieder melden,
damit die gucken, ist der erfüllt oder muss ich noch.
Aber es kann aber auch sein, dass die dann sagen:
„Ja hier, aus folgenden Erwägungen mit den anderen Revieren und so weiter,
erhöht doch mal, oder senkt doch mal diesen Plan.“
Senken hab ich noch nicht überliefert bekommen.
Also eher mehr als weniger.
Ich habe nur mehr gehört.
Weil?
Zum Beispiel gab es im Allgäu mal Tuberkulose im Rotwild
und dann muss ich Infektionsketten unterbrechen.
Achso. Okay, sozusagen als Seuchen-Bekämpfungsmaßnahme.
Ja dann gibt's aber wieder bürokratische Spitzen,
da hat einer da kommt Rotwild nur als Wechselwild
also nur sporadisch im Revier vor
und wenn der Abschuss von 30 Stück Rotwild kriegt
und kein einziges Stück sieht, dann hat er hinterher pro Stück eine Strafe von
ein Ordnungsgeld von 500 oder 1000 Euro.
Und dann fragt er sich natürlich: "Was soll das?".
Wie stellt man denn jetzt sicher...
Ich meine, Tiere können ja auch krank sein,
gerade wenn jetzt Tuberkulose auf einmal im Raum steht.
Da schießt man sich ja jetzt Nichtmal 10 Hirsche und sagt: „Yum, lecker!“
Muss man die dann auch noch medizinisch untersuchen lassen?
Aber hallo.
Ja natürlich.
Also in solchen Fällen ganz sicher.
Also Tuberkulose ist jetzt ein eher seltener Fall,
relativ gängig ist Schweinepest.
Also sieht man manchmal so "Schweinepest gefährdeter Bezirk",
das heißt da wird...
Das gilt dann auch für Wildschwein, sozusagen.
Das Problem dabei ist, wenn diese Schweinepest
auf Hausschweine übergreift, dann wird ziemlich weiträumig
der ganze Fleischhandel stillgelegt und die Bestände müssten dann auch
im Amtsdeutsch gekeult werden.
Tolles Wort, ne?
Sind überhaupt alles ziemlich tolle Worte.
Ja und dann ist im Grunde das eine ist halt Impfköder ausbringen,
was die Jägerschaft dann meistens als Amtshandlung stellvertretend für die
Behörde übernimmt und das andere ist halt wieder
Reduktionsabschüsse hinzukriegen, um die Infektionsketten aufzulösen.
Bedeutet praktisch, dass man
ein Schwein erlegt und dann ist innerhalb eines Landkreises irgendwo
ein Container aufgestellt,
da muss man dann alles hinfahren inklusive Aufbruch,
dann nimmt man Proben,
muss man bei alles fressen ohnehin tun also
gerade bei Schweinen auf Trechiden prüfen
Trichinen?
Trechiden ist ein Endoparasit also der sich von innen ansammelt
und sich im Muskelfleisch festsetzt und dann über
Ausscheidungen wieder überträgt.
Irgendwie so ganz grob.
Und den will man als Mensch eben auch nicht haben und
deshalb bei jedem Stück Schwein, Schwarzwild
eine Trechidenprobe, die wird dann an den Amtstierarzt
oder nur der normale Tierarzt eingeschickt
also ich jage nicht so viel auf Schweine,
aber auf jeden Fall wird überprüft und wenn man innerhalb
einer Woche keine Meldung erhält ist alles gut
und kann es verzehren.
So und Schweinepest ist dann halt nochmal da muss man...
Also muss man das immer bei den Schweinen, generell immer machen?
Ja, auf Trechiden muss man immer untersuchen
und auf Schweinepest da gibt's dann noch extra Proben
vom Schweiß muss man eine Probe
und ich glaube ein Stück aus dem Vorderlauf nehmen, in Tüten verpacken,
mit einem Begleitformular und in die Behörde,
in die Veterinärämter liefern, die dann ein Monitoring durchführen und dann...
Das erheben. Und bei Rehen ist das aber nicht so Pflicht.
Bei Rehen gibt's soweit ich weiß jetzt
keine Krankheiten, die eine Gefährdung für die menschliche Kultur bedeuten.
Also die haben schon mal so Magen-Darm-Erkrankungen, dann sieht man halt mit
verschissen im Spiegel also Hintern halt durch die Gegend laufen,
schleppen sich so dahin und die erlegt man natürlich.
Aber für das Fleisch spielt das dann keine Rolle, spätestens dann, wenn...
Ja bei denen, ja verwertet man nicht mehr.
Die haben manchmal zum Beispiel Rachendasselfliegen.
Das ist eine Fliegenlarve, die setzt sich im Rachenraum fest.
Die ist zum Beispiel nicht negativ fürs Wildbret.
Also wenn die bis dahin noch nicht so abgekommen und verhungert sind,
dann kann man die durchaus noch verwerten.
Das ist sowieso also diese erste Beschau also wie sieht ein gesundes Organ aus,
wie sieht eine also eine Leber muss zum Beispiel glatt und glänzend mit scharfen Kanten sein.
Der Geruch, der einem aus der Bauchhöhle entgegenkommt, ist schon
ein Signal für ist gesund oder nicht.
Ist da irgendwas?
Also, wie unangenehm sind diese Gerüche, mit denen man konfrontiert ist?
Wenn man die erste Mal eine Nase voll nimmt, dann weiß man nicht genau,
ob man das normal oder unangenehm finden soll.
Und meine Erfahrungskurve ist, so ist es eben.
Es ist ja jetzt auch sozusagen, zu dem Zeitpunkt
hat das ja auch Verwesung und so weiter noch nichts zu tun.
Also so riecht das Leben so würde ich sagen.
Also es ist eigentlich ungewohnt,
aber nicht unangenehm.
Also beim ersten Mal riechen...
Das ist neu, klar, anders.
Es ist neu und man ist noch nicht sicher.
Da kommt man dann sozusagen rein.
Das heißt, nach dem Schuss, der im Idealfall schnell
und mit möglichst wenig Drama und Schmerzen
für das Tier zu Ende geht.
Was nicht immer gelingt, wo man dann eben nochmal nach pirschen muss
und gegebenenfalls noch etwas ausgefeiltere Tötungsmaßnahmen nachlegen muss.
Nimmt man die Tiere, bricht man die Tiere auf
und dann muss man sozusagen erst mal
einen medizinischen Schnell-Check machen,
der sich eben mischt aus so einer Erfahrung, Wahrnehmungen, Geruch,
optischen Betrachtungen et cetera,
relativ zu dem jeweiligen Tier und den gesamt medizinischen Seuchen-Bedingungen,
die gerade so herrschen oder nicht herrschen.
Und dann belässt man einen Teil dort, also den Aufbruch.
Es sei denn, es gibt gute Gründe, wie das mit der Bleimunition in einigen Regionen,
nimmt man alles mit.
Wenn ich mir das so vorstelle, ich meine –
Wie schwer wird so ein Reh? Auch schon so...
Also ein guter Rehbock
20 Kilo ist jetzt nicht so viel.
Okay. Aber so eine Sau,
ich meine, wenn dann 160 Kilo irgendwie rumliegen.
Wie kriegt man die denn da überhaupt weg?
Winde.
Was für Freunde.
Ich meine, hast du so einen Pickup-Truck, irgendwie, mit einem Krahn?
Womit? Ich meine, das packt man jetzt nicht in seinen Pkw.
Man richtet sich dann natürlich drauf ein.
Also wenn ich auf so eine Schwarzwild jagt jetzt
alleine gehen würde
also es ist jetzt nicht so mein Primäres,
dann hätte ich mir jetzt ins Auto zum Beispiel eine Winde gepackt
oder mindestens ein Flaschenzug, um da was zu machen.
Also ich bin ja, ich habe teilweise 50/60 Meter,
um an den nächstem Weg zukommen und ich meine das ist
manchmal so ein Tier das rauszubewegen,
das ist halt schon echte Ackerei oder man hat halt ein
paar Telefonnummern, die auch mal spätabends aufstehen...
Okay, aber so im Normalfall, macht man Kabel ran
und mit einer Seilwinde zieht man das dann einfach durchs Gebüsch.
Stimmt es eigentlich, dass alle Jäger Subaru fahren?
Nee bewährt haben sich eigentlich...
Soll ich Marken?
Aber ist ja egal.
Also kleine leichte Suzuki Jimny zum Beispiel.
Oder Lada Niva ist voll geil.
Also wenig Technik.
Robust durchs Gebüsch fahren heißt immer Kratzer im Lack.
Scheißegal.
Je dicker die Karre wird, umso schneller bleibt sie stecken.
Verstehe, man will etwas, dem man nicht so schnell nachweint,
was aber genug Platz hat,
aber eben nicht so viel Gewicht auf den Boden bringt.
Oder was ich auch schon, ist eine andere Strategie,
die sagten halt eben so was wie einen VW Caddy.
Also eine große Ladefläche, niedrige Ladekante und
Gelände kommt quasi nicht vor, weil die meisten Waldwege mit Tempo 50
befahrbar sind mittlerweile
Okay, aber da muss man trotzdem unter Umständen auch ganz schön heben,
bis man irgendwie so ein fettes Vieh durch die Gegend bekommt.
Ich kann dir sagen.
Okay, und Wild, was man dann eben nicht selber verbrauchen will,
das wird man an diese Wildhändler los?
Die freuen sich?
Ja, also bei größeren Strecken kann man die in Anspruch nehmen.
Und im Prinzip ist ja diese Jagd in Deutschland auch die einzige Quelle
von Wildfleisch, oder?
Ja sobald ein Zaun drum ist, ist ja kein Wild mehr.
Es gibt dann Damwildgehege und Rotwildgehege.
Dann hast du halt im Grunde
einen kompletten Outdoor-Lebenswandel,
aber letztendlich werden die auch mit der Waffe geerntet.
Okay.
Aber die werden da sozusagen auch gehalten nur zum Zwecke dessen.
Mir ist grade gar nicht so klar,
wie groß der Anteil von Wildfleisch,
was jetzt in Restaurants oder so angeboten wird,
oder sonstwie, aus der Jagd stammt.
Ist das nennenswert oder ist das irgendwie verschwindend gering?
Ich sag mal wenn man so in die eher ländliche Gastronomie geht,
dann sind wild Gerichte in der Saison eigentlich normal.
Ich werde immer...
Dann sourced sich das sozusagen auch primär aus dem Jagdtrieb.
Das ist zumindest das Ideale.
Die haben, wenn die örtliche kleine Betriebe kennen,
haben sie natürlich die Verbindung zu den örtlichen Jagdrevieren oder
auch Forstbetrieben, die dann halt eben die Jagdjahr verantworten.
Und dann nehmen die ab.
Und sagen: "Alles was erlegt wird ab zu mir."
Ich bin dann nur manchmal, immer wo ich ein bisschen...
Ist halt so eine Denke, wenn irgendwo Wildgulasch
auf der Karte steht dann, fange ich an kritische Fragen zu stellen.
Welches Wild denn?
Taube, Kaninchen, Hirsch, Wildschwein?
Du meinst, weil es nicht spezifisch benannt ist...
Also es kann ja ein lustiges Potpourri.
Ich dachte der Begriff „Wild“ ist eigentlich eher für Rehe und so.
Was war nochmal die richtige Kategorie? Schalenwild?
Also Wild ist eigentlich der Sammelbegriff für alle Tiere die keinen...
Die nicht domestiziert sind.
Ich meine Wildgulasch, da kannst du ja alles durcheinander hauen.
Ich habe so ein bisschen immer im Gefühl gehabt,
es handelt sich da primär eigentlich um Hirsche und Rehe,
wenn man jetzt von Wild spricht.
Ja, die sind natürlich in der Kommunikation am vordergründigsten.
Könnte aber auch was anderes sein.
Ich hab auch schon Krähe gegessen.
Was ganz lustig ist, weil Krähe schmeckt fast ein bisschen wie Rindfleisch.
Ist aber auch ein Allesfresser und müsste damit eigentlich zur
Trichinenuntersuchung gebracht werden.
Aber? Wird er nicht?
Wenn du mit der Krähe zur Trichinenuntersuchung gehst die lachen dich aus.
Aber weil?
Weil das hat noch nie einer gemacht.
Das ist ja jetzt mal ein Argument.
Im Grunde wäre es aber nur konsequent.
Der Alexander Busch der hat mal
Grillpartys mit Krähen gemacht und alle fanden es total lecker.
Und da gibt's auch Rezepte als PDF zum Download.
Mit Krähenburger zum Beispiel.
Ab wann in unserer Wahrnehmung...
Also ich esse jetzt auch nicht dauernd Krähe.
Ich habs einmal probiert.
Der Konsequenz dann halber, aber...
Ich mein, ist ja nicht so, dass wir einen Mangel an Krähen hätten, oder?
Ja ganz im Gegenteil.
Werden die denn auch aktiv bejagt?
Hoffentlich!
Krähe ist eine der Arten, die extrem von
der Kultivierung der Landschaft profitieren.
Also überhaupt Nahrungsopportunisten, wie man sie nennt,
die eine Vielzahl an Nahrungsquellen haben.
Denen gehts prachtvoll in unserer Kulturlandschaft und
hochspezialisierte Arten, die eine ganz bestimmte Nahrungsquelle brauchen,
die vielleicht für uns nicht mehr wirtschaftlich tragbar,
auch nicht als Beifrucht, irgendwie möglich ist,
die haben ein Problem.
Und Krähe ist ganz sicher eine Siegerart.
So, wie der Fuchs, wie der Waschbär, dieser Mink.
Die profitieren davon und das ist dann eben wieder dagegenhalten.
Es geht nie um ausrotten, nie.
Aber man muss den anderen Arten halt auch
ihren Platz lassen.
Sie zumindest in einer reproduktionsfähigen Größenordnung zu haben,
wenn noch nicht mal vielleicht in jedem Landstrich aber zumindest
so grundsätzlich finde ich.
Ach, das ist alles so interessant.
Aber, jetzt kann man wahrscheinlich noch Tage und Wochen darüber reden.
Vielleicht mal zum Abschluss: Es gibt ja auch noch so...
Man hat ja auch so ein Bild vom Jäger.
Mit dem Jagdhorn, auf dem Weg durch den Wald.
Es hat ja so eine interessante Kultur, die sich sozusagen darum...
Also überhaupt Musik, weiß nicht,
vielleicht sollte man das nochmal ansprechen.
So dieses Horn.
Welche Funktion hat denn das?
Ist das jetzt sozusagen nur Feierei
oder erfüllt das in der Jagd auch tatsächlich noch eine Funktion?
Die Geschichte ist, das war das Smartphone des Waldes und der Felder.
Ein Kommunikationsmittel über weite Entfernungen.
Dafür hat man es eigentlich gebraucht.
Was wurde da so kommuniziert?
Anblasen des Treibens, jetzt gehts los,
aufhören zu schießen.
Hahn in Ruh heißt das Signal.
Treiber in den Kessel,
das Treiben voran oder...
Das sind dann so Melodien, so kurze Melodien.
Kurze, prägnante Melodien, die dann eben allgemeinverständlich
der Kommunikation dienen.
Und das Horn war die Wahl,
weil es durch diesen Druck so unglaublich laut sein konnte.
Genau, trägt über recht weite Entfernungen.
Und genügte dafür eben.
Aber das kommt jetzt nicht mehr zum Einsatz,
weil es irgendwie erforderlich wäre,
sondern jetzt ist das sozusagen nur noch so ein traditionelles Beiwerk.
Oder hat es noch irgendeine Funktion?
Also es wird rein für den praktischen Jagd Betrieb
rudimentär noch eingesetzt, weil bis ich alle angerufen habe
oder kein Netz da ist.
Im Wald ist das nicht immer so gut.
Nicht überall ist Berlin
Denk mal nicht, dass das hier so gut wäre.
Du ich habe am südlichen Ende der größten Stadt von Nordrhein-Westfalen,
nämlich Köln 1,1 Megabit im Download.
Also ich weiß wie Schmerzen sich anfühlen.
Immerhin.
Naja besser als in die Hose geschissen.
Ich sage mal im praktischen Bereich ist das Jagdhorn sicherlich
auf eine rudimentäre Funktion zurückgefahren, aber es ist nicht ganz weg.
Das ist es eben auch nicht.
Und darüber hinaus ist es halt eben...
Es fällt unter den weiten Teil der Brauchtumspflege
und insbesondere nach den Jagden das Strecke legen.
Also fällt eben in diesen ganzen Bereich rein, also...
Strecke legen, ist das Ausbreiten des erbeuteten Tieres.
Wenn die da alle so nebeneinander liegen.
Also nach der, wenn ich es erlegt habe
mein Reh, meinen Hirsch was auch immer, dann ist es zum Beispiel
ein mentales Innehalten, in dem ich den letzten Bissen gebe.
Also ein Bruch von einer bruchgerechten Holzart.
Fichte, Eiche zum Beispiel.
Ein Zweig und schieb den in den Äser, also ins Maul.
Das ist so,
also Gedenkmoment, also wenn man es getötet hat klingt auch doof.
Also es ist so eine, ich habe dieser Natur etwas entnommen.
Und das Strecke legen,
ist halt eben dieses ritualisierte alles zusammentragen.
Ihr wart alle da.
Der Tag ist gut gelaufen das ist unsere Ernte.
Also auch so ein soziales Moment.
Ein soziales Moment, aber es hat auch einen spirituellen Anteil,
um jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weit zu greifen.
Was Quatsch ist, ist den Hut zu ziehen zum Beispiel.
Wir stehen ja nicht am Grab.
Hat sich bei manchen eingeschlichen. Ist totaler Unfug.
Jeder hat so seine eigene Bedeutungswelt an der Stelle.
Ja und ich sag mal, das ist auch etwas,
was im ländlichen Raum noch erhalten ist,
dass dieses enge miteinander umgehen.
Ich habe zum Beispiel bei Frettierjagden,
wo auf Kaninchen wird mit Frettchen gejagt.
Da geht man mit zwei, drei wirklich guten Freunden,
auf die man sich echt verlassen kann.
Hat einen guten Hund dabei und zwei, drei
Frettchen, also kleine Marder.
Die lässt man in die Kaninchenbauten, die Springen irgendwann raus und
dann legt man die mit der Flinte.
Das sind eben flüchtiges schießen, wo ich im Schwenken durchaus
mal an meinem Kumpel vorbeikomme.
Da brauche ich auch Vertrauen zu diesen Menschen,
dass der nicht im falschen Moment schießt
Und dieses gegenseitige Vertrauen zueinander,
das ist ein echter Wert.
Und das wird durch solche sozialen Rituale auch noch gestärkt, meist du?
Das wird auch noch gestärkt und ich hör mal das ist eine
also das muss man sich ja auch mal klarmachen, wenn man
in einem Ballungsgebiet wohnt und wo alles
nur von Trends und Moden und Gewinnerzielung und Entertainment
und sonstigen Dingen getrieben ist,
dann sind die Menschen, mit denen man umgeht
auch sehr schnell austauschbar oder werden es zumindest
oder man braucht eine gewisse Disziplin, es nichts zu tun,
wenn einem irgendwo ein kleiner Streit am Gartenzaun nicht passt.
Auf dem Land habe ich einen Nachbarn für Jahrzehnte, vielleicht für mein Leben lang
und wenn ich mit meinem Auto auf einem Feldweg festsitze und
der Kumpel hat einen Trecker, dann will ich mir auch echt nicht verscheißen mit dem.
Ganz andere Abhängigkeiten, die da existieren.
Ja, dann habe ich andere Abhängigkeiten und das ist auch etwa also
ich bin jajemand, der aus der Stadt so in den ländlichen Raum vordringt und
ich genieße das wirklich dieses verbindliche miteinander umgehen.
Das ist ein sehr angenehmes Erleben.
Was hast du denn zurückgewonnen,
jetzt durch dieses ganze Eintauchen in diese Jagdwelt?
Dir hat ja einiges gefehlt.
Was hat sich dadurch wieder eingestellt?
Ja also so etwas wie im Kontakt mit dieser irdischen Existenz sein mit meiner eigenen.
Also meine also auch so etwas wie eine Fehlerkultur.
Eine Verantwortlichkeit für meine Handlungen.
Ein Abwägen ein Risiken aushalten können.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel mal Rotwild-Alttier, das
schonte ganz klar den rechten Hinterlauf.
Erlege ich es, um es vor weiterem Schaden zu bewahren
Also „schont“ im Sinne von humpelte?
Also lahmt, würde man beim Pferd sagen.
Oder lasse ich leben, weil vielleicht ist irgendwo ein Kalb,
was halt als kümmert sagt man also unbetreut sind.
Die finden auch keinen Anschluss mehr in der Sozialstruktur.
Das ist eine echt bedeutsame Güterabwägung.
Und wo man quasi vor einer Frage steht, egal was ich tue,
falsch ist auf jeden Fall oder auch richtig, da Kenn ich beides.
Das sind auch so Entscheidungen, die man eigentlich meidet,
oder auch sonst einfach so in der Form gar nicht hat.
Das erdet.
Genau das erdet, richtig.
Das bringt einen die Füße wieder mindestens auf die Erde, wenn nicht sogar, rein in die Erde.
Also es ist auch nicht so ganz einfach in Worte zu fassen.
Also ich meine, ich mache ja auch so eine Pilgerreise durch alle möglichen
Perspektiven, die die Jagd so zu bieten hat.
Von Ökologen über einen Priester über
Mit dem Jagdfunk.
Ja, mit dem Jagdfunk.
Und die Aspekte gehen nicht aus.
Die gehen nicht aus und alles hängt irgendwie zusammen und
also ist vielleicht nochmal ein Wort wert
also ich habe letztes Jahr
ein sehr eindringliches Erlebnis gehabt in dem ich halt
ja mit Kai Uwe Denker gesprochen habe und danach seine Bücher gelesen habe.
Das ist ein Berufsjäger aus Namibia,
der ist ja in der Wildnis quasi groß geworden und
führt Jagdgäste in dieser verbleibenden Wildnis.
Also in dem Zusammenhang war zum Beispiel
die sind am Atlantik zum Angeln gegangen und da gibt's Fischvorkommen,
da braucht man an den Angelhaken keinen Köder zu machen.
Du wirfst die Angel rein und da beißt quasi sofort was.
Also wenn man jetzt darum macht,
kann man sich einen großen Haufen Fische an den Strand legen
und die haben als Kinder angeln dürfen da unten
und die Auflage, die man ihnen gemacht hat war:
"Du darfst so viel angeln wie du willst, aber bevor du den zweiten Fisch fängst,
liegt der erste geschuppt, ausgenommen und küchenfertig zubereitet
bei mir in der Küche."
Das ist etwas, das hat glaube ich prägenden Wert.
Eine andere Geschichte
auch von einem Berufsjäger da unten.
Man muss sich das auch mal vorstellen, seine Familie auch mit relativ
kleinen Kindern ohne geladene Schusswaffe alleine zuhause zu lassen, ist fahrlässig.
In einer solchen Welt.
Und die Kinder müssen dann also was heißt die müssen, aber die werden mit mit der Waffe groß.
Und war also einer als relativ kleiner Junge ist der in einen Jagdrausch geraten und hat
irgendwie 30 Hühnervögel erlegt.
Kommt mit diesen Hühnervögeln nach Hause.
Und das war jetzt lange her,
aber dann hatte der Popo Kirmes dort kann man geteilter Meinung sein,
ob das nötig ist,
aber der durfte nicht eher wieder zur Jagd rausgehen, bevor alle Vögel
aufgegessen waren.
Das hat natürlich eine ganze Zeit gedauert.
Aber das vergisst man auch so schnell nicht.
Ja, aber das hält auch fürs Leben.
Und so entsteht halt einfach auch eine Respekt und eine
Respekt und eine Wahrnehmung für
die Welt von der man nimmt und in die man wieder hinein gibt.
Und die ist wichtig.
Die finde ich total wichtig.
In den Büchern,
man stelle sich vor, man kommt an ein Wasserloch mitten im Nichts
und drinnen steht ein Kudu-Bulle,
der schwer verletzt von Hyänen mitten im
Wasser steht also ins Wasser gerettet vor den Attacken der Hyänen.
Der knirscht mit den Zähnen vor Schmerzen.
Natürlich erlöse ich den.
Da kann ich so viel Natur Natur sein lassen, bringe ich einfach nicht übers Herz.
Und das sind Verantwortlichkeiten,
die ich in meiner in meinen Fähigkeiten
wirklich froh bin, die da angesammelt haben, dass ich mit solchen
Situationen zumindest die Chance habe, gut unverantwortlich umzugehen
im Sinne meiner ganzen Moralvorstellungen und meiner Werte,
die ich mitbekommen habe und die ich auch irgendwie versuche weiter zu entwickeln natürlich.
Ja Jochen, ich würde sagen,
unsere kleine Reise durch die Jagd,
findet jetzt erst einmal ihren Abschluss.
Vielen Dank.
Ich danke dir auch ganz herzlich.
Ich fand, das sind sehr interessante Einblicke und Gedankenanregungen.
Ja, dann bringen wir es jetzt auch zu Ende.
Vielen Dank für’s Zuhören hier bei CRE und wir hören uns bald wieder.
Und ich sag tschüß und bis bald.